ORDER THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY WHERE WE ARE HERE
FOR AN OVERSIGHT HEARING TO
DISCUSS SUMMER READING THIS
SPECIFICALLY HOW ELECTRIC
SYSTEM RELIABILITY HAS BEEN
PRIORITIZE SINCE THE ROTATING.
OUTAGES LAST AUGUST. WHERE WE
BEGAN I HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
TO GO OVER. WE ARE PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING- HERE AT THE
CAPITOL WEARING MASKS AT ALL
TIMES AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING NOT ONLY IN
THIS CHAMBER BUT THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE HAVE VERY
LIMITED SPACE. SO OUR PANELISTS
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
WE ALSO HAVE ONE COMMITTEE
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. WE ENCOURAGE THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING THE CALL IN
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SEGMENT OF THIS HEARING THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IT IS AREA CODE. 877-692-8957
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR
TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON THE TV SCREEN
ADDITIONALLY I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ORDER TO HEAR
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME WE
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS OR OTHERWISE IN PEACE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDING ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE
CHAMBER. OR REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WANT TO MAKE AN
IMPORTANT CLARIFYING NOTE TO
AVOID CONFUSION. TODAY'S
HEARING IS FOCUSED ON A
ROTATING OUTAGES. WHICH ARE
CALLED BY THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR FOR
A SPECIFIED PERIOD OF TIME TO
HELP EASE DEMAND ON THE
ELECTRIC GRID AND CONTROL THE
RISK OF A LARGER OUTAGE
OCCURRING. THE ROTATING OUTAGES
LAST AUGUST LASTED A FEW HOURS.
AND ROTATED FROM AREA TO AREA
SO NO SINGLE NEIGHBORHOODS
ELECTRICITY WAS DOWN FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME. THESE
OUTAGES ARE UNIQUE FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS. OR
PBS'S WHICH ARE CALLED BY THE
UTILITIES TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK. IN THOSE OUTAGES POWER IS
SHUT OFF ON AT RISK CIRCUITS
UNTIL THE WEATHER EVENTS SUCH
AS HIGH WIND FOR LOW HUMIDITY
IS LESSENED AND THE RISK OF
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE SPARKING
A WILDFIRE. IS REDUCED THIS
COMMITTEE DISCUSSED PS PS IS
DURING OUR OVERSIGHT HEARING IN
MARCH SO TODAY'S HEARING WILL
BE SQUARELY FOCUSED ON ROTATING
OUTAGES. ROTATING OUT IT IS
CALLED LAST AUGUST SERVED AS A
WARNING ELECTED RELIABILITY
MUST NOT BE TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
WHAT WAS INTOLERABLE WAS THE
POWER WAS TURNED OFF WHEN MANY
CALIFORNIANS WERE MOST
VULNERABLE. IN THE MIDST OF A
WEST WHY HE'D STORM THE SAW
RECORD HIGH TEMPERATURES A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WHICH LIMITED
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO SEEK
SHELTER AND PUBLIC INDOOR
SPACES. AND WITH FIRES RAGING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS I SAID
DURING OUR PREVIOUS HEARING ON
THE TOPIC IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THESE OUTAGES WEAKEN
OUR CONFIDENCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEMS OPERATOR
AND THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE SYSTEM RELIABILITY.
FOLLOWING THE VENTS LAST AUGUST
YOU THREE WROTE TO THE GOVERNOR
AND NOTED THAT YOU AND YOUR
AGENCIES SHARED IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR WHAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS UNNECESSARILY AND
DEWART. THIS COMMITTEE HAS
ASHLEY BACK TODAY TO DETAIL HOW
SERIOUSLY YOU'VE TAKEN THIS
RESPONSIBILITY WHAT PREVENTABLE
ACTIONS OCCURRED LAST AUGUST
THAT HAVE BEEN REMEDIATED FOR
THIS UPCOMING SUMMER. AND JUST
HOW PREPARED WE ARE. WHEN WE
MEET. EVER CHANGING ROAD
CONDITIONS. NOT ONLY THIS
COMING SUMMER BUT FOR MANY
SUMMERS TO COME. I WANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS SUMMER WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT TEST FOR THE STATE I
KNOW YOU HAVE RECENTLY STATED
HOW YOU ARE GUARDEDLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT MEETING
RELIABILITY. BUT WE NEED TO
HEAR THAT YOU'VE TURNED EVERY
OVER EVERY ROCK. THAT YOU
SCOURED EVERY POSSIBILITY I
CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH HOW MUCH A
RELIABLE POWER SYSTEM IT
UNDERPINS OUR ECONOMY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. PEOPLE DEPEND
ON ELECTRICITY FOR THEIR SAFETY
AND THEIR WELL BEING. BUT
ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA IS AT
THE VANGUARD OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY POLICY THE NATION AND
THE WORLD ARE WATCHING TO SEE
HOW WE INTEGRATE RENEWABLES BUT
ALSO WHETHER WE CAN INSURE
RELIABILITY WHILE DOING SO. I
KNOW YOU ALL FEEL THE WEIGHT OF
AND DEDICATION TO THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. AND I WELCOME
YOU TODAY TO SHARE THE ACTIONS
TAKEN TO ENSURE RELIABILITY
THIS COMING SUMMER. AND BEYOND-
AND AS I INTRODUCE OUR PANEL A
LET ME ALSO NOTE THAT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF EVENTS GOING ON THIS
MORNING OR THIS AFTERNOON- WE
HAVE A CAUCUS THAT IS-
CONCLUDING HERE SHORTLY AND WE
HAVE. BUDGET HEARINGS OF SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS MAY BE COMING
IN. AS WE BEGIN THIS- THIS
HEARING. NOW I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR PANEL. FIRST
PRESIDENT BASHER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FOLLOWED BY SHARE
HOT SCHULTZ OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND PRESIDENT
MANGER OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR LET
ME JUST SAY THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE- THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN DOING IN THIS INTERIM
PERIOD WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
INDIVIDUALLY AND- WITH SOME
SMALLER GROUPS TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU AND SO WE
ARE GETTING A SENSE THAT.
YOU'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY TO
CONFIRM THAT AND TO ELABORATE
ON THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE UNDER
WAY- DRESSING AND SO WE WELCOME
YOU NOW AND YOU MAY BEGIN IT
WILL START WITH. PRESIDENT
BATCH. WELL THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR AND CHAIR HOLDEN AND VICE
CHAIR PATTERSON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. BEFORE I GET UNDER WAY
I WANT TO SAY. INDEED W ARE-
PRESENTING TO YOU REMOTELY
CLEAR AT- THE OFFICES OF THE
COMMISSION HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M IN OUR CONFERENCE ROOM I AM
JOINED TODAY BY. EDWARD
RANDOLPH THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR ENERGY AND CLIMATE
POLICY. AND A BYGRANTED MAN
BECAUSE OUR DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. ALL THREE
OF US HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND-
THEREFORE WE ARE NOT WEARING
MASKS ALTHOUGH WE HAVE THEM
HERE WITH US. AND WE ARE AS YOU
CAN SEE- SITTING AT QUITE SOME
DISTANCE FROM EACH OTHER SO
THANK YOU. FIRST I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME AND
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR TO
BE BEFORE YOU TODAY AS A FOLLOW
UP TO LAST OCTOBER'S HEARING
AND PART OF THE STATE'S
PREPARATION FOR THIS UPCOMING
SUMMER. I WANT TO ALSO THANK
YOU CHAIR FOR EARLIER
ACCOMMODATING MY SCHEDULE AND
RESCHEDULING OF THIS HEARING
TODAY. TWO INDEED ARE THE
EIGHTEENTH. ONE OF THE LESSONS
FROM LAST AUGUST ISTHAT IT IS
CRITICAL WE ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND BETTER INFORM
THE PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES WE SEE AHEAD OF US.
THIS AND SUBSEQUENT SUMMERS THE
VARIOUS PUBLIC MEETINGS HOSTED
BY OUR RESPECTIVE INSTITUTIONS
OVER LEFT LAST YEAR INCLUDING
THESE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS HAVE SERVED TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THAT IMPORTANT
LESSON AND RESPONSIBILITY. IN
THAT SPIRIT WE HAVE ALSO
APPRECIATED FULFILLING YOUR
REQUEST REVISED MONTHLY REPORTS
TO THE COMMITTEE SINCE LAST
OCTOBER ON OUR PROGRESS IN
EXECUTING THE ACTIONS
RECOMMENDED IN THE FINAL ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS. AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE REPORTS OUR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVING
ALMOST NONSTOP TO IMPLEMENT
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS BY
THIS SUMMER WE WROTE TO THE
GOVERNOR LAST AUGUST THAT YOU
MENTIONED MR CHAIRMAN THAT WE
SHARED THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHAT HAD WHAT MANY.
CALIFORNIANS AND NECESSARILY IN
TOWARD AND WE COMMITTED
OURSELVES TO IMPROVING THE
STATE'S POSITION TO WITHSTAND A
SIMILAR EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
IN THE FUTURE AND TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY OF THOSE WE SERVE.
MEETING THIS COMMITMENT HAS
REQUIRED AN ENHANCED LEVEL OF
COORDINATION AND PROBLEM
SOLVING. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE GRATITUDE
AND THANKS FOR THE
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT THE
LEADERSHIP AND THE STAFF OF OUR
RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN SO DOING. TODAY
YOU WILL HEAR OF THE NUMEROUS
TASKS EACH OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS
AND PARTNERS HAVE COMPLETED TO
BETTER POSITION THE STATE. AND
THOUGH NO ONE CAN PREDICT THE
WEATHER AND RATE RESOURCE
CONDITIONS ON A GIVEN DATE WITH
A 100% CERTAINTY WE KNOW WE ARE
ARE IN A STRONGER POSITION THAN
WE WERE THIS TIME LAST YEAR.
FOR THE CBC'S PART WE HAVE
FACILITATED THE DIRECT
PROCUREMENT AND CAPACITY AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE. MEANINGFULLY
INCREASED DEMAND AND SUPPLY
SIDE RESOURCES FOR THIS SUMMER
AND NEXT SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE
ORDERED INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO PROCURE A MINIMUM
OF AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT 5%
OF RESOURCES FOR ALL CUSTOMERS
IN THEIR TERRITORIES
REPRESENTING AN EFFECTIVE
INCREASE OF THE PLANNING
RESOURCE MARGIN FROM THE
EXISTING 15% TO SEVENTEEN POINT
5% WE ALSO ORDERED THE
UTILITIES TO PILOT AN EMERGENCY
LOAD REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT
WILL GIVE DEMAND RESPONSE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER COMPANIES
PROVIDING NEW SERVICES TO
MANAGE THEIR ELECTRICITY DEMAND
THE ABILITY TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
THE RESOURCES CAN SUPPORT THE
GRIT. WE HAVE ORDERED THE
UTILITIES TO MODIFY THEIR
CRITICAL PEAK PRICING PROGRAMS
WHICH CHARGE A HIGHER PRICE FOR
ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION DURING
PEAK HOURS ON SELECTED DAYS. AS
PART OF THIS WEEK ORDERED
SEVERAL MODIFICATIONS TO THE
CRITICAL PEAK PRICING PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM IS MORE
EFFECTIVE AND RESPONSIVE TO THE
CRITICAL HOURS OF A GRADE
EMERGENCY. WE ALSO ORDERED THE
MODIFICATIONS TO EXISTING
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS TO
EXPAND PARTICIPATION INCLUDING
TEMPORARILY ALLOWING YEAR ROUND
ENROLLMENT IN THE UTILITY
INTERRUPTED INTERRUPTIBLE
PROGRAMS. FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
AND LARGE COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS
IN ADDITION WE INCREASED DEMAND
RESPONSE PROGRAM ENROLLMENT
INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT NEW
CUSTOMERS WE ALSO IMPROVED A
NEW STATEWIDE FLEX ALERT
PROGRAM TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE POSITIVE IMPACTS OF
CONSERVATION HELP CUSTOMERS
UNDERSTAND GREAT CONDITIONS AND
INFORM CUSTOMERS OF THE NEED TO
CONSERVE WHEN ENERGY DEMAND. IS
AT ITS HIGHEST. THE ABOVE IS
JUST WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS. THERE IS ALSO
AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF NEW RESOURCES
COMING ONLINE OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. FROM PRIOR FROM
PRIOR CAN A COMMISSION DOES
DIRECTIVES WITH TWO THOUSAND OF
THOSE MEGAWATTS COMING ONLINE
FOR THIS SUMMER. THE
COMBINATION OF PRIOR COMMISSION
DIRECTIVES AND DIRECTIVES FROM
ACTIONS IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS
I MEAN THERE SHOULD BE BETWEEN
THREE THOUSAND AND THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF NEW
RESOURCES ONLINE THIS SUMMER
COMPARED TO LAST WITH IN THIS
REPRESENTS A TENFOLD INCREASE.
OF THE STORAGE RESOURCES FROM
LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME SO THAT
IS REALLY TWENTY VERSUS TWO
THOUSAND A THOUSAND PLUS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SUMMER
RELIABILITY- DECISIONS ALSO
INCLUDE THAT TOTAL. SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS WE MADE ARE NOT
ONES FRANKLY WE CELEBRATE. SOME
OF THE INCREMENTAL CAPACITY WE
WILL DEPEND ON THE SUMMER ARE
NOT CLEAN RESOURCES BUT MOST OF
IT IS. IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE PURSUED THESE PAST FOR
THIS SUMMER. DURING LAST AUGUST
EXTREME HEAT WAVE WE ALSO
CONTENDED WITH COBIT NINETEEN
DRY CONDITIONS AND WILDFIRES.
AND THOUGH THOSE RISKS ARE
DIFFERENT THIS YEAR THEY REMAIN
CONSIDERABLE FACTORS AS WE
CONTEMPLATE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THE LOSS OF ELECTRICITY TO A
COMMUNITY. BUT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT ARE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE PROGRESSES
FORWARD AND WILL ONLY
ACCELERATE IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS TO COME. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE INDUCED EVENTS OF LAST
AUGUST ONLY FURTHER
CRYSTALLIZED THE NEED TO BUILD
A MORE RELIABLE GRID BY WAY OF
ZERO CARBON RESOURCES. THE
ORGANIZATIONS HERE HAVE
COLLABORATED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
IN DEVELOPING THE JOINT AGENCY
SENATE BILL ONE HUNDRED REPORT
THAT ASSESSED VARIOUS PATHWAYS
FOR MEETING ARE 1100% CLEAN
ENERGY GOAL OUR ORGANIZATIONS
ARE NOW COLLABORATING I'M
CRITICAL PLANNING EFFORTS THAT
WILL FACILITATE THE ASSOCIATED
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT. AT
THE CPUC SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD TO ENSURE
PROCUREMENT AT THE REQUIRED
PACE TO MEET THOSE GOALS.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
THE NATION IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF RENEWABLE RESOURCES
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
INNOVATIVE DEMAND RESPONSE
PRODUCTS AND TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. THE OUTAGES OF
LAST AUGUST WERE AN ACCEPTABLE.
BUT A SILVER LINING IS IT HAS
FURTHERED OUR RESOLVE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO POWER THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IN
THE WORLD AND TO LEAD THE FIGHT
AGAINST CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE
CHANGE. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
MY ORGANIZATIONAL PARTNERS FOR
THE WORK WE HAVE DONE TOGETHER
AND MUST CONTINUE TO DO
TOGETHER AND AGAIN THANK YOU
OUT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT BEFORE
YOU TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
TODAY'S DISCUSSION AND I WILL
NOW HAND IT OVER TO. THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION CHAIR DAVID
HEARTFIELD. HE'S SO MUCH FOR
THE BACHELOR AND THANK YOU SURE
HOLDEN BUSTER PATTERSON
PATTERSON NOT ENOUGH IS A
COMMITTEE. ISSUED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU ACCEPT IN OUR
DAVID HOPES WILL CHAIR THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. ARE IN MANY
WAYS I WOULD SAY THAT
SUPPORTING ELECTRIC RELIABILITY
BECAUSE OUR FIRST SECOND AND
THIRD. PRIORITY FOR ALL OF OUR
AGENCIES BECAUSE THE STAKES ARE
SO HIGH AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU
AT THE OUTSET THAT IN THE
TWENTY YEARS I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN CALIFORNIA ENERGY POLICY. I
HAVE NEVER SEEN COLLABORATION
AS CLOSE AS I'M SEEING IT TODAY
BETWEEN THREE AGENCIES- I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES- APPETIZER IN PCM
OR STAFF FOR REPORT THAT
LEADERSHIP I ALSO WANT TO
INTRODUCE MY NEWEST CARLY GET
THEIR TUITION SO THE CONDUCT OF
THE GOVERNOR. APPOINTED TO BE A
COMMISSIONER IN MARCH I'VE
ASKED COMMISSIONER GOING TO
FOCUS. SOLELY ON SUPPORT
ELECTRIC LIABILITY BRING HIS
CONSIDERABLE MODELING
FORECASTING AND INTERAGENCY
COORDINATION TALENTS TO BEAR
AMERICANS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO-
TO ANSWER MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS AS WE GO FORWARD. SO
AGAIN THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S
LEADING ROLE OUR- FOCUS IS
PRIMARILY. ON PERFORMING
STATEWIDE PLANNING- WHICH IS
THE DEMAND. I ANALYZE DIFFERENT.
APPLIANCE INTO TO ZERO. AND WE
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCE LAST
SUMMER THAT WE NEED TO BUILD
UPON OUR PAST NOTICES. AND
BUILDS A NEW ANALYTICAL
PRODUCTS SO THERE'S MISSION IS
DOINGTHIS. BY ENHANCING OUR
FORECAST IN A COUPLE WAYS WE'RE
EXTENDING THE DEMAND FORECAST
TO COVER A FIFTEEN YEAR.
HORIZON INSTEAD OF A TEN YEAR
HORIZON AND WE'RE USING CLIMATE
MODELS TO IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE
LIKELIHOOD OF EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS- WE'RE EXPANDING OUR
COUNTY FORECAST TO SAMMY WIDER
RANGE OF WEATHER PATTERNS AS
YOU RECALL LAST SUMMER THE-
HOTTEST RELIABLY RECORDED
TEMPERATURE IN WORLD HISTORY
HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA. IN
AUGUST. WE'RE ALSO LAUNCHING
SOME NEW RELIABILITY
ASSESSMENTS ARE RELIED RELIABLE
ASSESSMENTS WILL LOOK AT NEAR
TERM MID TERM. AND LONG TERM-
IN THE NEAR TERM WE'RE
ASSESSING SUPPLY DEMAND UNDER
DIFFERENT WEATHER CONDITIONS
AND WE CONDUCTED THE SUMMER
RELIABILITY ASSESSMENTS THIS
YEAR. AND WILL BE CONDUCTING
SUMMER ASSESSMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH YEAR COMING
CORD FOR MID TERM WE'RE LOOKING
AHEAD FIVE YEARS. AND FOR LONG
TERM WE'RE LOOKING AT A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT COMBINATIONS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY BUILD OUT AND
TRANSMISSION CONFIGURATIONS.
FOR DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES WERE EVALUATING THEIR
PERFORMANCE BENEFITS AND HOW
THEY IMPACT RELIABILITY AND
WE'RE ALSO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE PC AND CONSOLE. ON PLANS
FOR CONTINGENCIES EVERY CASE
ANOTHER EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
LIKE WE DID LAST SUMMER. WE
IDENTIFY ALL THE RESOURCES THAT
WE CAN CALL ON. AND THEN
LEVERAGING THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WORK IN SOME OTHER
AREAS I THINK YOU'LL BE HAPPY
TO KNOW THAT ARE EXCITING
DIVISION OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS LOOKING. AT SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO EFFICIENCY EVER
EXISTING FLEET WE HAVE SEVENTY
NINE JURISDICTIONAL THERMAL
PLANTS- IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
INTERVIEW COMMISSIONS- LEAD TO
BE OVERSEE. THERE WERE KERN
CURRENTLY REVIEWING AND
APPROVING PETITIONS FOR HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO ADDITIONAL MEGAWATTS
OF INCREMENTAL EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES AT SEVEN POWER PLANTS.
AND ANOTHER TWENTY THREE HALF
MEGAWATTS OF EQUIPMENT UPGRADES
FROM BATTERY ENERGY STORAGE
SYSTEMS UP TO EIGHTY NINE
MEGAWATTS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
AVAILABLE BY THE START OF
SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY ONE THESE
ARE. TYPICALLY HOT GAS PATH
UPGRADES. AT- THERMAL PLANTS.
WE'RE ALSO WE'RE WITH THE P.
CARE. OR IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
RESPONSE. I WAS A GENERAL
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN PUNCHING
BELOW OUR WEIGHT OR DEMAND
RESPONSE WITH A LOT OF URGENCY
TO GET THAT- IMPROVED AND SO WE
CONVENE IT ROUND TABLE. WITH
ALL THE AGENCIES- WITH THE KEY
DEMAND RESPONSE PROVIDERS IN%
OUR CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
STRATEGIES TO MAXIMIZE THE
POTENTIAL DEMAND SPONSOR IN THE
SHORT TERM. AS WELL AS LONG
TERM SO WE HAVE SOME PROGRESS
ON THAT THAT I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT FROM MY
COLLEAGUE. MISTER ALSO EARLIER%
THIS YEAR WE RELEASED OUR DRAFT
LOAD MANAGEMENT STANDARDS AIMED
AT ENABLING MASS MARKET DEMAND
FLEXIBILITY. THROUGH AUTOMATED
RESPONSE TO GREAT SIGNALS- AND
OUR OUR CROWN JEWEL RESEARCH
PROGRAM THE EPIC PROGRAM
ELECTRIC PROGRAM INVESTMENT
CHARGE. HAS NOW PROVIDED
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GRANTS TO DEVELOP TECHNOLOGIES
TO SUPPORT DEMAND FLEXIBILITY I
WOULD SAY GENERALLY. THE MODEL
IS CHANGING FROM YOU KNOW THE
OLD VIEW OF SEEING DEMAND IS
THIS FIXED THING. TO NOW- WHAT.
WE SEE WHAT WE CAN MANIPULATE
THAT DEMAND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT MERGING FIELD- AND SO
WERE ESTIMATED FROM THAT
INVESTMENT THAT TIME OF THE
TWENTY FIVE MEGAWATTS WITH A
FLEXIBLE DEMAND CAPACITY. FROM
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AN EIGHTEEN MEGAWATTS
FROM IRRIGATION PUMPING LOAD.
SHIFT. I WILL BE AVAILABLE THIS
SUMMER. ALL OF THIS IS. TO THE
WORKER. IN THE DOING. OTHER BUT
RELATED AREAS- BEFORE I TURN
THE MIKE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ALAN MINSTER BECAUSE SO. I DID
WANT TO JUST RECAP AND SOME OF
THE KEY CLEAN ENERGY MILESTONES
BECAUSE THIS IS. OF COURSE
CLIMATE IS UNDERLYING A LOT OF
THE THREATS REFUSING TO BE
GREAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. THE PROGRESS WE'RE
MAKING ON CLEANING UP- DIRECTOR
GRANT SO LAST YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA- WE WERE AT 63%
CARBON FREE ELECTRICITY COURSE
ON ROUTE 2100% BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE- AND- WE'VE ALSO SEEN. A
LOT OF HELP COMING FROM
CUSTOMER INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
BEHIND THE METER SO TODAY WE
NOW HAVE FORTY THOUSAND BEHIND
THE METER ENERGY STORAGE
SYSTEMS DEPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA.
ADDING FORTY OF THOSE A DAY.
WE'RE AT ONE POINT TWO MILLION
ROOFTOP SOLAR. ENERGY SYSTEMS
IN THE STATE TODAY. AND WE'RE
ADDING FOUR HUNDRED A DAY- AND
THEN ELECTRIC VEHICLES LONG
TERM ARE ALSO REALLY AN ASSET.
TO THE GRID WERE NEARLY NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOCTORS
VEHICLES THAT HAVE BEEN PART IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ADDING SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY A DAY. ON AS YOU
ALL KNOW LAST YEAR AND I LOOK
AT PEOPLE'S BECAME THE NUMBER
ONE EXPORT FROM THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD NOW WANT TO
PASS WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
GET TO. EIGHT MILLION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AND THAT TOGETHER REPRESENTS
MORE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND.
MEGAWATT HOURS OF STORAGE AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
CONSIDERING THAT 96% OF A
VEHICLE'S USEFUL LIFE IS SPENT
PART. THAT IS ACTUALLY
IMPORTANT RESEARCH AND THESE
TWO THINGS. ARE COMING
TOGETHER- ENERGY STORAGE. HELLO
VEHICLES BE WE'VE BEEN SO IN
ACTUALLY TAKING. USED ELECTRIC
VEHICLE BATTERIES CAR BATTERIES
THAT. MAY NOT HAVE THEIR FULL
NAME PLATE RATING BUT STILL
HAVE A LOT OF USEFUL LIFE AND
RE PURPOSING THEM- A
STANDALONE- ENERGY STORAGE
SYSTEMS THAT CAN SUPPORT ENERGY
STORAGE FOR BUILDING SO. THIS
IS WHERE INNOVATION- REALLY CAN
CAN SUPPORT OUR LONG TERM
NEEDS. I WITH THAT I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE AGAIN
FOR ALL YOUR DIRECTION AND
LEADERSHIP ON BOTH CLEAN ENERGY
SOLUTIONS. AND OTHER GREAT
RELIABILITY AND ALL PASSED TO
MY TO MY COLLEAGUE GOT
PRESIDENT ELEMENTARY CASTLE.
THANK YOU CHAU SHELLED. OUT
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN
FIGHTER PATTERSON. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE WITH YOU TODAY. I'M ALSO
JOINED BY THE CASES SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER MARK ROSS LEADER. IT IS
YOU MAY RECALL I DURING THE AYE
SO SHORTLY AFTER LAST SUMMER'S
HEATWAVE THE FACT. IT WAS STILL
BEING ACCLIMATED TO THE ISSUES
WHEN OCCURRED BRIEFLY BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE AST OCTOBER.
SINCE THEN I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE I SO AS BEEN
UNEQUIVOCALLY FOCUSED ON BEING
AS PREPARED AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
SUMMER WE'VE TAKEN THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS AND WORK HAND IN HAND
WITH THE C. P. C. C. E. C. TO
AVOID A REPEAT. OF LAST YEAR'S
OUTAGES. I'VE BEEN VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT BASHER CHAIR WHO
SHOW THEIR TEAMS. THE TIME AND
ENERGY WE HAVE SPENT WORKING
TOGETHER ON THESE ISSUES HAS
ALLOWED US TO IDENTIFY THE
PRESSURE POINTS THAT MANIFESTED
DURING LAST AUGUST'S HEAT WAVE.
AND FOCUSED ON THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY ACTIONS IN ADVANCE OF
THE SUMMER. INDEED SHAREHOLDERS
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT NO STONE
HAS BEEN UNTURNED IN SEARCHING
FOR RELIABLE OUTCOMES THIS
SUMMER. AT THE I SO WE'VE TAKEN
MULTIPLE ACTIONS SINCE LAST
SUMMER TO ENSURE EFFICIENT
MARKET OPERATIONS HI
AVAILABILITY OF EXISTING POWER
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION WITH MARKET
PARTICIPANTS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
THE ACTIONS WE'VE TAKEN INCLUDE
CLARIFYING MARKET RULES FOR
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA'S LOADS
EXPORTS AND TRANSFERS ACROSS
THE ISO GRID. SHE'S
ESTABLISHING MINIMUM CHARGING
REQUIREMENTS FOR BATTERY
STORAGE RESOURCES SO THEY CAN
RETURN ENERGY TO THE SYSTEM
AFTER SUNSET DURING STRESS
GREAT CONDITIONS MAKING SURE
THAT OUR MARKETS AND STRONG
PRICE SIGNALS FOR IMPORTS AND
DEMAND RESPONSE. ENSURING THAT
PLAN GENERATOR OUTAGES TO DR
GRADE RELIABILITY DURING
PERIODS OF PEAK DEMAND IN
STREAMLINING THE GRID
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS TO
EXPEDITE NEW SUPPLY. WE'VE ALSO
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND NEIGHBORING
BALANCING AUTHORITIES TO ENSURE
COORDINATION AND CLEAR CHANNELS
OF COMMUNICATION HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED GOING INTO THE
SUMMER. FROM THE OPERATORS IN
THE CONTROL ROOM FLOOR TRUCK
COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT WE
HAVE ASSESSED EVERY DIVISION TO
FIND WAYS TO PROVIDE TIMELY
ADVANCE INFORMATION ABOUT
CREATED WEATHER CONDITIONS TO
PROMOTE AFFECTED DECISION
MAKING AN IMPACTFUL DEMAND
RESPONSE PROGRAMS. OUR
ANALYTICAL MODELS HAVE BEEN
UPDATED WITH LAST YEAR'S
WEATHER EVENTS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE A MORE ACCURATE
FORECAST OF THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD. BASED ON OUR ASSESSMENT
OF THE SUMMER WE'VE SEEN
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE GENERATION
STACK. THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF
MANY OVERALL CAPACITY HAS
IMPROVED COMPARED TO TWENTY
TWENTY WITH APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. THIS TOTAL INCLUDES
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF NEW
RESOURCESCOMING ONLINE IN THE
WHOLESALE MARKET TO SERVE OUR
NET PEAK DEMAND COMPARED TO
THIS TIME LAST YEAR. AND AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
NEW RESOURCE CAPACITY SOME OF
WHICH WILL COME FROM BEHIND THE
METER UNDER EMERGENCY LOAD
REDUCTION PILOT PROGRAM
INITIATED BY THE C. P. C. WE'VE
ALSO NOTED THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HANDLING
EXTREME TEMPERATURE EVENTS HAS
IMPROVED WITH INCREASED
MAINTENANCE ON THERMAL
GENERATORS THIS PAST WINTER.
AND HEALTHY TRANSMISSION
CONNECTIONS TO ADJACENT REGIONS
WHILE HYDRO CONDITIONS ARE
FORECAST TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
BELOW AVERAGE THE DIGITAL
MEGAWATT SECURED BY THE STATE
AGENCIES PUTS US IN A BETTER
POSITION. THAN LAST YEAR. DOES
THAT MEAN THAT WE ARE IN THE
CLEAR. NOT NECESSARILY. I HAVE
USED THE TERM GUARDED OPTIMISM
BECAUSE THE STEPS WE HAVE TAKEN
TOGETHER WITH THE CPUC NCC
CLEARLY PLACE US IN A BETTER
POSITION RELATIVE TO LAST
SUMMER. HOWEVER THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT RISK FACTOR FOR
GRID RELIABILITY REMAINS
EXTREME HEAT. PARTICULARLY HEAT
THAT SPREADS ACROSS THE WIDER
WESTERN UNITED STATES. ANY
CONTINUES TO GET HOTTER EVERY
YEAR WE ARE NOTICING EXTREME
HEATWAVE EVENTS ARE BECOMING
MORE FREQUENT AND INTENSE. AS A
RESULT THE GREAT WILL CONTINUE
TO REMAIN VULNERABLE TO HIGHER
LOADS DECREASED IMPORTS DURING
A BROADER WEST WHY KEEP WAY
THAT THAT LIKED WHAT WE SAW
LAST YEAR. ITS IMPORTS TRY OUT
AND WE'RE LIMITED TO CAPACITY
THAT'S RIGHT SECURED UNDER
RESOURCE ADEQUACY CONTRACTS
WERE FACING THE POSSIBILITY OF
SCARCITY OF ENERGY SUPPLY THIS
SUMMER. FINALLY THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES AFFECTING SUPPLY
AVAILABILITY. REMAINS ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT THREAT.
CALIFORNIA'S RELIANCE ON
IMPORTS REQUIRES INCREASED
COLLABORATION WITH OUR ENERGY
NEIGHBORS AND BETTER
COORDINATION DURING EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THIS AND IDENTIFY COORDINATED
SOLUTIONS SHOULD ANOTHER EVENT
OCCUR. THE CASE SO HELD A
SUMMER READING THIS LEADERSHIP
ROUND TABLE WITH REGIONAL
UTILITY EXECUTIVES AND
CONDUCTED TABLE TOP EXERCISES
WITH UTILITIES AND ADJACENT
BALANCING AUTHORITIES. TO WALK
THROUGH GRADE SERIOUS AND FIND
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT IN OUR
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CQC AND
OTHERS WERE ALSO RE
ESTABLISHING AND EXPANDING THE
PAID ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN FOR
FLEX ALERTS AND WE WILL AGAIN
BE DEPENDING ON CONSUMERS. TO
ANSWER THE CALL FOR
CONSERVATION. WHEN THE GREATEST
MOST IN NEED WE REMAIN VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF CONSUMERS
ENERGY SAVING ACTIONS FROM LAST
SUMMER WHICH PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN AVOIDING
EXTENDING PERIODS OF ROTATING
OUTAGES. WE ALSO INTEND TO HOLD
A SOME RECESSED BRIEFING FOR
THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
A FEW WEEKS. AT THE END OF THE
DAY I BELIEVE WE ARE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES THE SUMMER COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR NEW MARKET.
ENHANCEMENTS ADVANCED
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
AND A GREATER. OF OPERATE RISK
WILL PROVIDE TREMENDOUS VALUE
IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HOLDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
PERSPECTIVES WITH YOU TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR OPENING
STATEMENTS AND WE ARE ALL HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANKS
AGAIN. WELL THANK YOU- AND
CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR-
YOUR THOUGHTFUL OVERVIEW ALL
THREE OF YOU. AND HIGHLIGHTING
THE- THE CHANGES THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON FROM LAST SUMMER- I
JUST WANTED TO ASK A QUICK
QUESTION JUST TO GET US STARTED
AND I'LL TURN TO ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. BUT
I'M CURIOUS IF YOU COULD
CONTRAST WHAT HAPPENED IN
AUGUST VERSUS WHAT HAPPENED IN
SEPTEMBER OF LAST. LAST YEAR.
IN BOTH INSTANCES AN INTENSE
HEAT WAVE BROKE OUT. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND FLEX ALERT. WERE
CALL. YET WE EXPERIENCED
ROTATING OUTAGES IN AUGUST BUT
AVOIDED THEM IN SEPTEMBER. WHAT
WAS DIFFERENT IN SEPTEMBER HEY
WE ALREADY APPLIED THE LESSONS
LEARNED IN AUGUST AND HOW MIGHT
THAT INFORMERS AND OUR RESPONSE
THE SUMMER. IT FOR ANYONE OF
YOU BUT- SO WHAT BY ALL MEANS.
CEMEX ARE YES I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE INITIAL. ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I THINK SO I THINK
THERE WERE THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF LESSONS LEARNED ON THE VERY
FIRST WEEKEND IN AUGUST
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH VERY
QUICKLY. I THINK IT THE I SO WE
IDENTIFIED THE SENATE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH SCHEDULING
POWER AND OUR ABILITY TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT THE
PHYSICAL SUPPLY DEMAND BALANCE
WISE THAT WE QUICKLY RECTIFIED
SO THAT WAS ADDRESSED TO AYE
WITHIN EVEN THE FIRST WEEKEND
THE SECOND THING I THINK REALLY
THE BIG DIFFERENCE MAKER. AS
KEY AS TEMPERATURES CONTINUE TO
BE VERY VERY HOT ACROSS THE
BOUNCER BOX IN THE WEEKEND WAS
THAT THERE WAS JUST A
SIGNIFICANT MOBILIZATION OF
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATION
COORDINATION AND ON THE AND
THAT SIGNIFICANT DEMAND
RESPONSE EFFORT I MEAN THE
EFFORTS THAT INDUSTRY AND
CONSUMERS MADE CALPERS CONSERVE
POWER ACROSS. OR SO I THINK IT
WAS ALL HANDS ON DECK ALL
AVAILABLE RESOURCES ON BOTH THE
GENERATION AND THE DEMAND
SOCCER MADE AVAILABLE IN THE
STATE WAS ABLE TO COME TOGETHER
AND PREVENT ADDITIONAL ROTATING
OUT IT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TRY TO DO OUT FOR THIS
UPCOMING SUMMER IS TO SORT OF
SYSTEM THAT TIES A LOT OF THOSE
EFFORTS THAT WERE DONE ON A BIT
MORE OF AN AD HOC BASIS. LAST
SUMMER MUCH GREATER COORDINATED
CONTINGENCY PLANNING FOR BOTH
SUPPLY RESOURCES AND DEMAND
SIDE RESOURCES AND ANOTHER
THING THAT'S GOING TO BE I
THINK VERY DIFFERENT THIS
SUMMER THAT WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE ADVANTAGE OF LAST SUMMER IS
THAT OUR COMMUNICATION IN
ADVANCE WARNING SYSTEMS ARE
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
ENHANCE THE I SO WILL BE
PROVIDING SEVEN DAYS OF ADVANCE
WARNING FOR TEMPERATURE
EXCURSIONS AND HEATING ADVANCED
REGARDING REAL TIME UPDATES. ON
GREAT CONDITIONS GETTING THAT
INFORMATION WIDELY DISSEMINATED
TO THE UTILITY UTILITY
COMMUNITY AND THE OPERATING
COMMUNITY AND THE FLEX ALERT
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAVE A SET OF VERY DISTINCT AND
VERY ACTIONABLE MESSAGES THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS.
SO THAT THEY CAN ALSO BE PART
OF THE RELIABILITY EQUATION IF
WE DO INDEED RUN INTO STRESS
GREAT CONDITION SO IT TAKES
BOTH A HEALTHY SUPPLY STAR
WHICH THE CPC ENERGY COMMISSION
OF HEALTH INCREASE FOR THE
SUMMER AND A REALLY STRONG AND
COORDINATED DEMAND RESPONSE AND
CONTINGENCY ACTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS SUMMER RESULT. IN
DIFFERENT OUTCOMES THAN LAST
SUMMER. SHAREHOLDERS I'LL ADD
TO THAT. IN HI I DO- WANT TO
THAT I APOLOGIZE LITTLE BIT.
EARLY IT BECAUSE HE WASN'T EVEN
IN THE CHAIR WHEN WE EXPERIENCE
THE AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER- HEAT
STORMS. AND RELATED FIRE-
SITUATIONS SO. IT IS THOSE VERY
THINGS THAT LEN ENUMERATED JUST
NOW I THINK THAT IT WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- THAT WE
DID YOU USE THE WORD
COMMUNICATIONS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WAS EXTREMELY
INSTRUMENTAL. IN HELPING US
COORDINATE. AND HELPING ALL OF
US IN TERMS OF THE DEMAND
RESPONSE- INITIATIONS AND
PROGRAMS- AND I IT TRULY MADE
THE DIFFERENCE- HAVING SAID
THAT. THEY THERE WAS A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE HAD TO DO. THAT
NONE OF US WANTS TO DO AGAIN-
THERE WERE IN PART THANKS TO.
CHAIR HI SHIELDS WHO.
PERSONALLY CALLED THE
DEPARTMENT OF NAVY. AND GOT THE
SHIPS OUT IN THE SAN DIEGO
HARBOR TO. MOVE OFFSHORE ENERGY
AND MOVE ON TO. THEIR THEIR
DIESEL- THERE WAS A LOT OF THAT
THAT WE ALL HAD TO CALL UPON-
IN TERMS OF. RESOURCES THAT WE
TYPICALLY WOULD NOT WANT TO
HAVE ENGAGE BECAUSE OF THE
POLLUTION. AND BECAUSE OF THE
HARM TO ON. OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
GOALS- SO IT WAS THAT
MOBILIZATION. EFFORT THAT- WE
REALLY- I HAVE SAID TO MY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ALL IN THE
FOXHOLE TOGETHER. AND WE WENT
TO BATTLE AND WE DID IT AT
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR SEVERAL
DAYS. AND IT TOOK A LOT OF HARD
WORK FROM OUR THREE AGENCIES
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO-
L. IT DID A VERY. GOOD JOB- AS
SHE WHAT WE HAD TO DO AND WHAT
THOSE THINGS LET US TO START
FOCUSING ON FOR THE SUMMER.
I'VE YEAH I'LL JUST ADD ALSO
JUST FOR THIS SUMMER JUST A
COUPLE OTHER PIECES OF
ELABORATION IF I MAY HAVE
TRAVELED AND IS YOU KNOW THE
CAPACITY ADDITIONS THAT HAVE
MADE THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
FOR THE SUMMER- PARTICULARLY
THE BATTERIES IN THE ENERGY
STORAGE RESOURCES WERE PERHAPS
HOSTED TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF BATTERY SPRUCE EXPLICITLY
DESIGNED. RIGHT ONTO THE GRID
TO ADDRESS THAT. FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE THAT WE RAN INTO LAST
SUMMER OF. STRESSED WHY
FOLLOWING SUNSET YOU KNOW WE
ARE WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
OUR RENEWABLE RESOURCE FLEET
BEHAVES BEHAVED EXACTLY AS
EXPECTED AND WE AS WE'VE KNOWN
AS WE'RE MOVING TOWARD A SYSTEM
THAT RELIES MORE ON VARIABLE
RESOURCES LIKE WITH IT SO THAT
WE NEED TO COMPLEMENT THAT.
WITH OTHER RESOURCES SO
FORTUNATE THIS SUMMER WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A MUCH EXPANDED
ENERGY STORAGE FLEET WHICH WILL
PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
HELPING ABSORB EXCESS ENERGY
DURING THE COURSE OF THE DAY IN
AND FEEDING THAT BACK INTO THE
GRID AFTER SUNSET TO HELP.
SUPPORT RELIABILITY SO THAT'S
GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE- THIS SUMMER
RELATIVE TO LAST YEAR AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- SURE HARSH
OUT OF MENTIONED IN HIS
PRESENTATION THAT. WE'RE-
FIGHTING THE LOWER WEIGHT I
THINK OR SOMETHING TO THAT
EXTENT- AS IT RELATES TO A
DEMAND RESPONSE I WANTED TO GET
SOME SENSE OF HOW YOU'RE- ALL
SEEN THAT. HE'S COMING TOGETHER
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE ROBUST AS
WE GO INTO- THE SUMMER MONTHS.
YEAH WELL I AM BUT I'M
CERTAINLY NOT DIG INTO THE CODE
NINETEENTH SO- BUT I WOULD SAY
ME. WITH TO DEMAND- DEMERITS
ONCE WE HAVE BEEN PUNCHING
BELOW. BUT IT'S BEEN A MAJOR
FOCUS FOR US IN TERMS OF OUR
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENTS WE FUNDED- THAT WAS
LIKE ON CONNECT WHICH IS DOING
A MASSIVE PROGRAM THIS SUMMER
TO REACH OUT TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS
AND GET PEOPLE THE NON
PROGRAMMABLE THERMOSTATS LIKE
NEST UNDER THE PROGRAM NOW- AND
ACTUALLY MAYBE LA YOU COULD
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DEMAND RESPONSE EXPERIMENT FOR
THE SUMMER. I THINK IT'S I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL I THINK I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. FOR US TO
STATE I THINK CRIME I THINK.
FOR BOTH THE CBCP CCMA IN THE
GOVERNOR SO YOU KNOW IT WITH IN
OUR IN OUR FINAL ROUTE CAUSE
ANALYSIS. WE PUT OUT RESOURCE
PERFORMANCE INFORMATION ACROSS
THE WIDE SPECTRUM OF RESOURCES
AND WE IDENTIFIED SOME ISSUES
IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PATCHES WITH. THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE RESOURCES RELATIVE TO
RESOURCE ADEQUACY EXPECTATIONS
WE DID NOTE. TO CERTAIN AGREES
THAT IN SOME CASES WE SAW SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE
OF DEMAND RESPONSE RESOURCES.
THAT INSTIGATED A I THINK A
VERY VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION
WITH THE DEMAND RESPONSE
COMMUNITY WHICH I THINK WE ALL
LEAD INTO AND LISTEN VERY
CAREFULLY WHERE WE'RE WE LOOK
AT THE DATA. AND WE TRY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
RESOURCE CAPABILITIES AND THE
ACTUAL RULES FOR THE DEBATERS
FUNDS PROGRAMS AND SODA COULD
BE MADE A CONCERTED EFFORT-
WITHIN THE THREE STE AT
ENTITIES. TO LEAN IN AND TO
LOOK FOR SOME ADDITIONAL WAYS
WE MAY BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS. TO BETTER ENABLE
THOSE RESOURCES TO MEET THEIR
PERFORMANCE CAPABILITIES THAT I
THINK THIS SMMER WILL BE
PARTICULARLY TRUE. WITH RESPECT
TO THE THIRD PARTY RESOURCES AT
THE AYE SO WE'VE MADE SOME
CHANGES TO OUR BASE LINING
METHODOLOGY WHICH SORT OF
ESTABLISH A DEMONIC IT'S WHICH
THEIR PERFORMANCE IS MEASURED.
THE HOPE IS TO SEE IF THAT
OPENS UP SOME ADDITIONAL
CAPABILITY. THE CPC'S EMERGENCY
LOAD REDUCTION PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO REALLY CARRY OUT.
CAPABILITY WITH STRONG PRICE
SIGNALS- TO ACCESS THAT
CAPABILITY. AND THEN OF COURSE
THE FLEX ROUTE COMPLEX ALERT
PROGRAM WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DID USE LAST YEAR IS GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
IN TERMS OF ITS BEST MESSAGING.
VISIBILITY IN IN THE CLARITY OF
WHAT WILL BE ASKING AND
ENCOURAGING OF CONSUMERS SO ALL
THREE OF THOSE LEGS THE THIRD
PARTY. PERFORMANCE THE BIG E.
L. R. P. PROGRAM. IN THE FLEX
ALERT SHOULD WORK IN TANDEM TO
HOPEFULLY GET EVEN GREATER
DEMAND RESPONSE FROM SOCCER
BLASTER AND WILL COME OUT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE SUMMER.
CONSOLIDATE MESSAGES TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOGETHER. I WITH THE D. OUR
COMMUNITY. THIS IS YOUR
CAROLINE JUST FOR THE ARE TO
GET COUPLE THINGS. THAT- I
COLLEAGUE HAVE ARE ALLUDE TO
AND I MENTIONED IN MY OPEN
REMARKS AS- AS ELLIE IT- JUST
SPOKE ABOUT THE EMERGENCY LOAD
REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT C. E. L.
R. P. PILOT. AND THAT CAME OUT
IN THE DECISIONS THAT WE PUT
FORTH IN MARCH. AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO ALLOW PG&E AND SCE
EDISON. AND SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC. AND I SAID TO RELY ON
ADDITIONAL REDUCTIONS IN THE
ELECTRIC USE DURING TIMES OF
HIGH DEMAND. WHEN THERE WILL BE
LIMITED GENERATION TO MEET THAT
DEMAND. AND AGAIN THIS IS A
PILOT EMERGENCY PROGRAM- AND
IT'S REALLY. DESIGNED TO BE A
MEASURE OF LAST RESORT.
DEPLOYED THE WHEN THE GREAT. AS
AT THE EDGE AND SO THAT'S WHY
I'M SAYING ITS EMERGENCY AND
IT'S PERHAPS ONE TOOL THAT IS
GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL FOR US
BUT ONE WE- WE HOPE WE NEVER
GET THAT CLOSE- ALSO AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
WE HAVE MODIFIED THE I. O. U.'S
CRITICAL PEAK PRICING PROGRAMS.
THE C. B. P. IS A RETAIL RATE
WHEREBY THE LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES CHARGE. HIGHER PRICES
OF FOR ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION
DURING THE PEAK HOURS. OF THE
SELECTED DAYS- FOR THAT PROGRAM
WE HAVE SHIFTED THE CPP. A
WINDOW TO THE HOURS OF FOUR PM
TO NINE PM THAT P. CONNECT
PEAK. TO BETTER ALIGN WITH THE
GRID NAMES. INCREASE THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF CPP EVENTS
ALLOWED PER YEAR. AND ARE
PROVIDING CUSTOMER EDUCATION
WITH A FOCUS ON IMPROVING. THE
PARTICIPATION AND THEN. ALSO
HAVE MY- SOME OF OUR EXISTING
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS FOR
THE YEARS OF TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO THROUGH A HOST OF
CHANGES INTENDED TO EXPAND THE
ELIGIBILITY AND INCREASE
INCENTIVES- THESE INCLUDE. THE
I'LL USE BASE INTERRUPTIBLE
PROGRAM WHICH WE CALL THE FIFTH
THE I. P. AND THE CAPACITY
BUILDING PROGRAM. SEVERAL
INDIVIDUAL TERRACE AND
GRANDJEAN- S. C. EDISON. THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A SECOND
PHASE OF THE VIRTUAL POWER
PLANT PILOT TO TEST
DISPATCHABLE TECHNOLOGIES
DURING GRID RELIABILITY OF THIS
INCLUDING. D. E. L. R. P. WHICH
I JUST TO MAKE MENTION AND THEN
L. IT WILL SPOKE ABOUT THE-
FINDING A NEW STATEWIDE FLEX
ALERT PAID MEDIA CAMPAIGN WITH
A FOCUS ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
DIGITAL MEDIA AND I WOULD ADD
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
IN HIS NAME REVISED ADDITIONAL
MONIES. FOR THE FLEX ALERT ON
CAMPAIGN SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE MOST YOUR SOME OF THE
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS THAT
ON THE CPUC HAS- EITHER STARTED
OR- MODIFIED IN LITERALLY TWO
DECISION ONE DECISION IN AND-
JANUARY- SKEWS ME THAT RIGHT
AND ONE IN MARCH. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ELLIOTT
AND DAVID FOR YOUR RUN REMARKS
AND DEMAND RESPONSE AS WELL.
THANK YOU I DO APPRECIATE THE
EVEN THE COLLABORATION ON
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS YOU ARE
ALL WORKING IN HARMONY I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND TO SHOW
AND DEMONSTRATE TO ALL WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS. HEARING JUST
HOW- NOT ONLY COLLABORATIVE
YOU'VE BEEN BUT HOW YOU ARE
ALSO GOING OUT IN ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE DETAILED ISSUES
GRANT EARLY. THAT REQUIRE THAT
KIND OF ATTENTION SO THEY WERE
IN A STRONGER POSITION GOING
INTO THE SUMMER MONTHS
APPRECIATE THAT I'M GONNA PAUSE
ON MY QUESTIONS I'M GONNA TURN
TO DR QUIRK AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHO MAY HAVE.
QUESTIONS ASK. OUR THANK YOU
ALL FOR RIDE BE RESPONSIVE TO
US REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR ALL
BEING HERE. SO YES I'M BILL
CORK AND I'M GOING TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT A PROBLEM THAT IS
GOING TO OCCUR SOMETIME IN THE
FUTURE. WHERE WE DON'T WANT TO
RUN OUT OF ENERGY IN THE WINTER.
WHEN WE'RE GONE TO RENEWABLES
WHICH'LL PRIDE DOMINANTLY BI
SOLAR- CALIFORNIA WIND ACTUALLY
GOES TO THE OFFSHORE WIND GOES
DOWN DURING THE WINTER- SO WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF.
ENERGY GENERATION DURING THE
WINTER I BROUGHT THIS UP WITH
THE CLIFF OF COMMISSIONER OF
CPUC COMMISSIONER CLIFF RUSSIA
OFTEN. AND WHAT DO WE DO- FOR
THE WINTER- MONTHS AS WE
APPROACH A HUNDRED PERCENT-
PEOPLE HAVE VARIOUS IDEAS YOU
CAN'T DO IT WITH BATTERIES THEY
WON'T HOLD A CHARGE LONG ENOUGH
AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH LITHIUM
AND COBALT ANYWAY. BOB YOU
CAN'T DO IT WITH- PUMPED
STORAGE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE NEAR ENOUGH. SO PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT CREATING HYDROGEN
FROM SOLAR AND STORING IT.
WHATEVER WE DO WHEN YOU STORE
SOMETHING FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME IT'S LIKE PUTTING MONEY IN
THE GROUND- IT'S GONNA BE VERY
EXPENSIVE. THAT MUCH- PROJECT-
BUT- YOU KNOW WHAT'S BEING DONE
NOW TO LOOK AHEAD. TO THAT
ISSUE OF RELIABILITY FOR THE
WINTER MONTHS AS WE GET CLOSER
21100% RENEWABLES. HIS QUICK I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT A BIT- SO.
FOR ONE THING- WHAT ONE OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION HAS AT THIS
POINT FUNDED ABOUT SIXTY ENERGY
STORAGE DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE. WITH
VIRTUALLY EVERY CHEMISTRY
MENTIONED LITHIUM ION WHICH IS
THE PREDOMINANT FORMA STORES
TODAY AND CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW
THE LEADER IN THE SPACE BUT
THERE'S A BUNCH OF OTHER
CHEMISTRIES VANADIUM IRON
CHROMIUM AND OTHERS WE JUST
FIND IT COMICAL FORM ENERGY.
WHICH HAS A VERY VERY VERY LOW
COST BUT VERY INEFFICIENT
ROUNDTRIP EFFICIENCY SO LOOK AT
MY OWN IS ABOUT 90% ROUGHLY
ROUND TRIP EFFICIENCY THIS
CHEMISTRIES ABOUT 50% CONTRA
PROFICIENCY BUT IT'S SUPER
CHEAP- AND THERE IS A CHANCE
WHAT WE HAVE SURPLUS RENEWABLES
AND SURPLUS SOLAR DURING THE
DAY. ARE TO ACTUALLY CHARGE
WHEN YOU HAVE EXTRA ENERGY AND
USE IT FOR A SEASONAL STORAGE
SO THAT IS A AN EMERGING FIELD
THAT I DO SEE GROWING- IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT ALL OF THE POWER TO
BE SOLD FOR EXAMPLE WE WANT TO
DIVERSITY OF TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING WIND INCLUDING
OFFSHORE WIND WOULD FOR PUTTING
A LOT OF WORK INTO RIGHT NOW.
INCLUDING GEOTHERMAL AND OTHERS
AND SO DIVERSITY OF RENEWABLE
GENERATION IS AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE STRATEGY AUGMENTED
BEEFING UP STORAGE GENERALLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET- IN
REVISE IS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO JUST DO LONG
DURATION STORAGE SO THIS IS
GOING TO BE A MAJOR. FOCUS FOR
US- IN THE YEARS AHEAD. I'LL
JUST ADD TO IF I MAY UM.
SENATOR THAT AT THE SEAT U. C.
WE I AGREE SO. WITH THE SAN-
IDEAS. THE CHAIR JUST PUT
FORWARD AND THAT IS A DIVERSITY
OF OUR PORTFOLIO OR THE
PORTFOLIO IS SO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. AND WE HAVE THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS THAT DOES DICTATE
INDEED- A THREE YEAR FORWARD
LOOKING- PROCESS THAT THEN
LEADS TO- BORDERS OF A
PROCUREMENT THAT WE AT THE
CPUC- PUT FORWARD SO- THE
DIVERSITY OF THE PORTFOLIO IS
REALLY CRITICAL AS AT THE
CHAIRMAN SAID WE DON'T JUST
WANT TO SURVIVE ON SOLAR AND
SOLAR. BACKED UP BATTERY AS
WELL BUT- WE'RE ENCOURAGING IN
OUR I. R. P. PROCESS AND
DECISION WHICH WILL BE
FORTHCOMING IN THE NEXT MONTH
THE CURRENT ONE THAT WILL COVER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. A DIVERSE
PORTFOLIO SO I'M GONNA TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUE EDWARD RANDOLPH TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
THAT I MISSED THAT YOU LIKE TO
ADD OR THAT WOULD ADD ON TO
WHAT- CHAIR PUNCTUAL JUST SENT
HER- THANK YOU PRESENT A
BACHELOR AND I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE REALLY COVER IT I'LL
JUST ADD. ON IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MODELING FOR THAT ARE DONE WITH
AN I. R. P. COMPARE THAT WITH
MODELING HAVE BEEN DONE- WITH
THE SB ONE HUNDRED REPORT-
MODELING THAT'S BEING DONE AT A
RP IN RELATION TO- SCOPING
PLANS BUT THEN ALSO VERY
IMPORTANTLY MODELING HAVE BEEN
DONE BY- VARIOUS ACADEMIC
ORGANIZATIONS. OTHER GROUPS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THEY'RE
CONSISTENTLY SHOWING- THE ROAD
MAP TO GET TO THAT NINETY
PERCENT- CARBON FREE- IS COST
OF. COST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO GET
THERE AS LONG AS WE PURSUE A
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO THAT
INCLUDES- A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT RESOURCES THAT CAN
OPERATE IN DIFFERENT TIMES OF
DAY- GETTING TO THAT NEXT TEN
PERCENT- MAY BE MORE OF A
CHALLENGE BUT- YOU KNOW I
PERSONALLY THINK LET'S GET TO
THE NINETY PERCENT- AND THEN
KEEP PUSHING THROUGH THERE. BUT
THERE ARE NOW ALSO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT MODELING EFFORTS IT
CHAU- THE RESOURCE DIVERSITY
MIXES WE CAN FOLLOW TO GET TO
THAT- 100% THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND YES R. I. R. P. PRECEDING
WILL HAVE SOME DECISIONS COMING
OUT IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS-
THERE'S BEEN SOME JUDGES
RULINGS OUT THERE THAT YOU KNOW
INDICATING NEED FOR- SOME BILLS
OUT VERY SOON OF GEO THERMAL-
OF THAT LONG DURATION STORAGE-
THAT STORAGE CAN HELP BOTH
COVER YOU- FOR MULTIPLE HOURS
BETWEEN THE DAY AND THE NIGHT
BUT THEN ALSO- THE SEASONAL
STORAGE OUT THERE- AND- YOU
KNOW WE'LL HAVE A DECISION OUT
THERE THE BILL'S ON. ON THE
JUDGE'S COMMENTS PLUS COMMENTS
WE'VE HEARD- FROM STAKEHOLDERS
IN THAT PROCEEDING. I THANK YOU.
FOR I HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO
TO SOMEONE ELSE FIRST IF I
COULD YEAH BUT WE WILL COME
BACK TO YOU APPRECIATE THAT- SO
MEMBER OF ARCADIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
THE THREE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
WITH US IT'S OBVIOUSLY AS
PRESIDENT BETTER POINTS OUT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT. THE POWER STAYS ON FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION AND
CLEARLY THEY DIDN'T DEDICATION.
THAT IS EVIDENT IN THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE TO DATE TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE IN A BETTER PLACE
THIS SUMMER. REALLY GRATEFUL TO
HEAR US TALKING ABOUT INCREASED
ENERGY STORAGE I THINK IT'S SO
CRITICAL TO OUR RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO AND I THINK THAT
THAT. IT OFTEN I HEAR PEOPLE
SAY OH THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE. TO INCREASE NATURAL
GAS AND I THINK THAT WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING IS REALLY THE HEART
OF WHAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO
WHICH IS STORE CLEAN ENERGY TO
ENSURE IT'S AVAILABLE DURING
THAT PEAK DEMAND. AND SO I'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT I'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT DEMAND
RESPONSE I WANT TO TOUCH ON AND
THE THIRD ROUTE BECAUSE THE YOU
ALL IDENTIFIED- WHICH WAS THAT
SOME PRACTICES IN THE DAY AHEAD
ENERGY MARKET EXACERBATED THE
SUPPLY CHALLENGES UNDER HIGHLY
STRESSED CONDITIONS AS I READ
THAT THAT'S A FANCY WAY OF
SAYING THAT WE WERE EXPORTING
ENERGY ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH WHEN
WE NEEDED IT SO BADLY- RATHER
THAN USING THE ENERGY BEING
CREATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I KNOW YOU THEN SUSPENDED
CONVERGENCE BIDDING WHICH WE
SAW ON THE DAYS THAT FOLLOWED
THAT THAT ALLOWED US TO EXPORT
LESS ENERGY BUT ON AUGUST
FIFTEENTH THAT WE WERE ACTUALLY
EXPORTING ENERGY AND THAT IS A
MAJOR REASON WHY WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH ENERGY TO MEET HELP TO
ME CALIFORNIA'S DEMANDS THAT
DAY. AND I JUST WANT TO EXPAND
ON WHAT WE'RE DOING TO ADDRESS
THAT I KNOW YOU PUT THAT
CONVERGENCE MEETINGS BACK THAT
SEEM TO BE WHAT ADDRESSED IN
THE SHORT TERM BUT IT APPEARS
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO OTHER
THINGS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
NOT IN THE POSITION TO BE
EXPORTING ENERGY AGAIN WHEN WE
HAVE HEAT EVENTS THIS SUMMER.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND I'LL- TRY TO
ADDRESS IT IS DIRECTLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN RAISED. NUMEROUS
TIMES. I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE- JUST WHERE
IS TRANSPARENT AND AS CLEAR AS
WE POSSIBLY COULD ABOUT ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. AND IT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT ON A DAY
AHEAD BASIS. ARE GOING INTO THE
AUGUST FOURTEENTH FIFTEENTH
TIME FRAME. OF THE ISO DID.
INDICATE THAT HE COULD SUPPORT
GREATER EXPORTS I IN A DAY
AHEAD MARKET. MIND YOU WE WERE
STILL ANTICIPATING BEING A
SIGNIFICANT NET IMPORTER BUT AT
DURING THAT DURING THAT TIME
FRAME BUT IT LOOKED AS THOUGH
BECAUSE THERE ARE QUITE A FEW
ENTITIES THAT WERE ATTEMPTING
TO BUY OUT OF OUR MARKET. AS IS
COMMON. IN THE COMBINATION WITH
THE CONVERGENCE BETTING THAT WE
THOUGHT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT MORE EXPORTS ONCE WE
SAW THAT. WE WERE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PURCHASE BACK THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THAT ENERGY IN
THE SUBSEQUENT DAY HOURLY AND
REAL TIME MARKET SO WE'VE MADE
THAT DIFFERENCE OUT BETWEEN DAY
AHEAD AND ARE REALLY REAL TIME
SUCH THAT BY THE TIME WE
ACTUALLY GOT INTO THE HOURS
DISPATCH. ON THE FOURTEENTH
FIFTEENTH WE WORDS. IMPORTING I
THINK APPROXIMATELY SIX
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF ENERGY WE
WERE STILL BY FAR AND AWAY THE
NET IMPORTER IN THE MOST OF
THAT IMBALANCE HAD BEEN
RECTIFIED. THAT SAID WE CLEARLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT GOING
FORWARD WE ADDRESS THE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RESIDUAL
UNIT COMMITMENT PROCESS MADE
SURE THAT WE ARE GETTING THE
MOST ACCURATE SCHEDULING
BEHAVIOR WE POSSIBLY COULD. AND
MADE SURE THAT IF WE THAT IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE MERGING OF OUR PHYSICAL AND
FINANCIAL MARKET MECHANISMS
THAT WE HAD CLARIFIED AS WE ARE
ABLE TO CLEAR THEM UP VERY
QUICKLY. IN ADDITION TO SINCE
LAST AUGUST- WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
WORK. I WISH WITH. EIGHT AND
BECAUSE ACROSS. THE TO ME SURE
THAT THE SCHEDULING PRIORITIES
FOR LOAD SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA
FOR EXPORTS OUT OF OUR MARKET.
ENTRY OTHER ENTITIES WHO WIELD
POWER ACROSS OUR SYSTEM ARE
CLARIFIED TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT
POSSIBLE SO WE WERE VERY
TRANSPARENT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MENTION- THAT THAT
WAS A- FACTOR THE CONSTRUCTING
TRIBUTE TO THE STRESS THE-
PRECONDITIONS. YOU KNOW WE HAD
THOSE MARKET MECHANISMS IN
PLACE FOR MANY MANY YEARS WORK
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND THEY
WERE CERTAINLY NOT A PROBLEM
UNTIL WE GOT TO THE OUTER EDGE
OF OUR RESERVE MARGIN AND SO
THE OTHER VARIABLES COMPETITION
REALLY CREATE THE PROBLEM SO IT
CERTAINLY BY ITSELF. I WAS NOT
GOING TO GET WAS NOT GONNA
SOLVE THE WHOLE PROBLEM WE SAW
EVEN GREATER. LOAD FORECASTS IN
SUBSEQUENT DAYS IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE MOBILIZATION- THAT YOUR
WHOLE SHIELD AND PRESIDENT
PATRICK TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
WE WOULD HAVE HAD ADDITIONAL
ROTATING OUTAGES EVEN WITH
THOSE FIXES TO THE MARKET SO I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO
OWN IT AND THAT THEIR ISSUES
BUT IT WAS FIVE. CERTAINLY NOT-
THE LONE VARIABLE- THAT
CONTRIBUTED THE OUTAGES AND ALL
THE OTHER CHANGES THAT WE'RE
MAKING. IN INCOME IN
COORDINATION WITH THE STATE
AGENCIES ARE ESSENTIAL. FOR
RELIABILITY GOING TOWARDS UP
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION. I AND
I HOPE THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO.
THANK YOU AB ALSO TO ADDRESS.
AND THE I'M SURE ALL OF YOU
SIDE BUT THERE WAS A MARCH
THIRTY FIRST ARTICLE BIG KQED
CAME OUT WITH THIS GUY SAYING
THAT- SHUT DOWN RATHER THAN
TURN UP OF THE PENDERS FACILITY
BY A PG&E 8EDULING.
COORDINATOR I GUESS THE
QUESTIONS WERE RAISED IN THAT
ARTICLE ABOUT WHETHER THAT WAS
AS- INDICATED ACCIDENTAL
WHETHER THEIR INCENTIVES IN
PLACE TO INCENTIVIZE AND I OWE
YOU THAT ALSO CONTROLS ACCESS
TO ENERGY DURING. A SHORTAGE.
AS WE SEE POWER THE COST OF
ENERGY GOING UP. SURE AS IT IS
IN CALIFORNIA WHETHER THAT WAS
INTENTIONAL OR NOT OR WHETHER
THERE IS INCENTIVE OR NOT TO DO
THAT THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT WE
SAW. YOU GUYS SO PUT OUT A
REQUEST TO P. GINNY THE
SCHEDULING COORDINATOR THEN
REACTED THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
YOU HAD INSTRUCTED AND I'M
SEVEN BORN STEEN AS HE
MENTIONED IN THE ARTICLE SAID
YOU KNOW ARE WE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNICATIONS ARE
CLEAR IN THE WITH THE ISO IS
AFTER CALLOUS OF ASKING FOR IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THESE
EVENTS. SO THEY WERE NOT EVEN
THOUGH WHETHER THAT WAS THE
FINAL TIPPING POINT AS
INDICATED OR JUST ONE OF SOUND
LIKE A LOT OF FACTORS WE NEED
TO BE GETTING IT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM ENSURING CLEAR
COMMUNICATION OF OUR ENERGY
GREAT THINGS LIKE AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR SO I WANT TO KNOW HOW
THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED YEAH
VERY MUCH SO NO GOOD AT THE TWO
THOUSAND. YOUR QUESTION AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN- THIS IS ANOTHER
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE
IDENTIFIED YOU KNOW IN IN OUR
EVALUATION OF ALL THE EVENTS OF
AUGUST FOURTEENTH THE FIFTEENTH
WE WENT BACK AND WE LOOKED VERY
CAREFULLY AT THE DATA. WE
LOOKED WE LISTENED TO ALL THE
COURT REVIEWED ALL THE
CORRESPONDENCE BETWEEN
OURSELVES AND PG&E AND
UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW I'M SURE
THERE WERE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT DISPATCH
ORDERS DELIVERED DURING THOSE
PERIODS THIS WAS ONE WHERE THIS
THERE WAS A COMMUNICATION MIX
UP- WITH THE PLANT OPERATOR. IN
THE UTILITY AND I KNOW TO THEIR
CREDIT P. JEANNIE ACTUALLY
SPOKE PUBLICLY AND OPENLY IN
IN- IN THIS. LAST YEAR AND- WE
CERTAINLY DO NOT SEE AN AND SO.
FOR THEM WHAT'S TO BE.
GENERATION IN EVEN MORE PRO
NINETY. CLEAN PORTLY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF MARKET MONITORING
OUR INDEPENDENT MARKET MONITOR.
I HAD ACCESS TO JUST. REBEL
AMOUNTS OF DATA WENT BACK AND
REVIEWED EVERYTHING AND FOUND
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE OF
WITHHOLD STRATEGIC WITHHOLDING
OR MARKET MANIPULATION DURING
THIS PERIOD SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S- IMPORTANT ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ENERGY MARKETS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IN YOUR SECTOR
EVENING. VERY VIGILANT AND
DILIGENT BUT CERTAINLY IT WAS
AN UNFORTUNATE COMMUNICATION
EXCEPT. I WAS CERTAINLY BY FAR
AND AWAY NOT THIS WEEK THE
SWING ISSUE THAT THAT WITH THE
CITY BUT THE STATE AND THE
DISTRUSTING DITIONS THE HEAT.
AND THE LOADS AND ALL THE OTHER
VARIABLES ARE MUCH MUCH MUCH
BIGGER. CONTRIBUTING FACTORS-
AND I THINK THAT THAT ISSUE HAS
BEEN RECTIFIED. AND GOING
FORWARD WE CERTAINLY WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT ALL
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN OURSELVES
AND CERTAINLY THE UTILITIES IN
THERE TOO AND THEY'RE GONNA
CHARGE BECAUSE CLEAR AND
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE CAN YOU SAY
HOW. IT'S BEEN RECTIFIED. YEAH
I MEAN. JEFF WELL FIRST OF ALL-
A COUPLE THINGS. LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS- IN ADDITION TO HOSTING.
THE READING THIS ROUND TABLE
WITH LEADERS FROM EIGHTEEN
UTILITIES AND ASSET OWNERS
AROUND THE WEST REVIEWING ALL
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR. OUR SYSTEM OPERATORS
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING TABLE TOP
EXERCISES WITH THE UTILITIES.
AND ALL OF THE ADJACENT SYSTEM
OPERATORS TO GO RIGHT THROUGH.
THE SET OF OPERATING SCENARIOS
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS
PLAYBOOKS. THAT GOVERN
COMMUNICATIONS AND DISPATCH
BETWEEN THE SYSTEM OPERATORS
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
AREN'T ANY OTHER POTENTIAL
MISTAKES THAT WERE. THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S OUR PARTICULAR
SITUATION WAS. ABSOLUTELY THE
EXCEPTION TO THE RULE I THINK
THE VAST VAST VAST MAJORITY OF
DISPATCHES A COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN OURSELVES AND UTILITIES
AND UTILITIES THEY'RE- IN THE
SCHEDULING COORDINATORS ARE
ASSETS WORKS JUST FINE. IT'S
UNFORTUNATE WE HAD THAT ONE
INCIDENT- AND I BELIEVE IT'S
BEEN RECTIFIED AND WE'LL. WE'LL
KEEP OUR EYE ON THE BALL GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU I HAVE ONE
LAW QUESTION. IT ONLINE. THANK
YOU AND THIS ONE'S FOR
PRESIDENT ROGER. AND WE'VE
MENTIONED A LOT THE VALUE OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR IN BEHIND THE
METER RESOURCES ADAM I THINK-
YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
OF YOU AND I THINK THAT'S RIGHT
ONE OF THE THINGS. AND THAT IS
YOU MAY KNOW I'M WORKING ON AND
I KNOW THAT THEIR PCS SAID
THEY'RE WORKING ON IS NOT ONLY
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE BEHIND
THE METER RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR DEMAND RESPONSE
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL.
BUT ALSO SO WE CAN DEPLOY THAT
ENERGY IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE HAD
ENOUGH ENERGY BEHIND THE METER.
TO AVOID THESE- ROLLING BACK
OUT SO I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
P. YOU SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING
TO ENSURE THAT THAT. BEHIND THE
METER ENERGY IS MORE MEANINGFUL
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBER ON. THE
BEHIND THE METER RESOURCES
ISSUES SAID I HAVE. PLAYED A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE. IN ON OUR
CLEAN ENERGY- AND RELIABILITY
OBVIOUSLY OF THE OF THE GRID.
AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS- AVAILABLE
FOR CUSTOMERS WHO WANT
INSTALLED BEHINDTHE METER
SOLAR. STORAGE LIKE THE SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND THE NET. ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM- SOME BEHIND THE METER
STORAGE SYSTEMS ARE SIZED TO
HAVE EXCESS ENERGY THAT COULD
BE EXPORTED TO THE GRID.
HOWEVER WHEN THEY- WERE
INTERCONNECTED TO THE ELECTRIC
SYSTEM THE CUSTOMERS DID NOT
ALWAYS ELECT TO HAVE THE- I. O.
U.'S NOT COMPLETE- A
DISTRIBUTION IMPACTS STUDY
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW.
AS A NECESSITY OR HAVE THE AYE
SO COMPLETE A DELIVER ABILITY
STUDY SO THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE ARE DOING AND I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
CONCENTRATION AND- DEVOTION TO-
TO THE DIFFERENT BEHIND THE
METER PROGRAMS I'M GONNA ASK.
MY COLLEAGUE AND RANDOLPH TO
ADD ANY OF THE IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT YOU HAVE RAISED MEMBER-
AND ANSWERS TO SOME OF THEM-
AGAIN THANK YOU PRESIDENT
BADGER ON THE ONE THING I WOULD
ADD ON TO THAT IS. WHAT WE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT IS THE
EMERGENCY LOAD REDUCTION
PROGRAM- AND THAT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE DETAIL TO
IT ALLOWS- VARIOUS- ENTITIES
TO. OUR BED IN OUR TOP FOR-
EITHER DEMAND RESPONSE
RESOURCES OUR GENERATION
RESOURCES- TO THE ICE SO TO THE
AYE- TO THE GRIT- IN THE EVENT
A OF WORK IS CALLED. ONE OF
THE- RESOURCES IS ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE EMERGENCY
LEVEL REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT WE
HOPE THEY DO PARTICIPATE AND-
IT IS- WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
REFERRED TO AS NET EXPORT OF
BEHIND THE METER STORAGE AND
ALLOWING- BEHIND THE METER
STORAGE THAT IS INTERCONNECTED
TO THE GREAT IN A WAY WHERE
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO ALREADY NET
EXPORT- TWO BILLION TO THE- ERP
AND PARTICIPATE THERE- THAT SET
UP AS A PILOT PROJECT SO THAT
WE CA- GET GREATER
UNDERSTANDING. OF WHAT THE
CAPABILITIES OF THOSE RESOURCES
ARE ON IN BETTER DESIGNING
MARKET RULES- MORE OTHER RULES
AROUND THOSE PROGRAMS IN FUTURE
YEARS SO THAT WE MAKE SURE
THEY'RE GETTING COMPENSATED FOR
THE VALUE TO PROVIDING- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME- THEY'RE.
PROVIDING THE VALUE THEY'RE
GETTING COMPENSATED FOR. THANK
YOU I FOR THAT I. THE WORK THAT
DOING HOPEFULLY CAN MOVE THAT
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO THIS
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR
CALIFORNIA. DURING THE
INTERESTS YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I DO
WANT TO APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS WERE MADE EARLIER
ABOUT THE SUMMER OUTAGES-
DURING THIS HEAT WAVE MOST
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE ASKING
PEOPLE DURING THE PANDEMIC TO
STAY HOME SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WERE EXPECTING TO
HAPPEN THAT THERE WOULD BE A
GREATER. DEMAND AT THAT TIME.
IT ALSO IS A STARK REMINDER OF
HOW MUCH WE RELY ON THE GRID IN
OUR THAT DAILY LIVES. I THINK
THAT GIVEN OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE USE THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THESE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THEM
HERE. AND ALSO CONSIDERING OUR
EXISTING NEEDED TO MAKE THE
GRID MORE RELIABLE IT SEEMS
THAT WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING RESOURCES. TO
OFFSET DEMAND AND ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THE CLEANEST OPTIONS
AVAILABLE. HI MIKE MY QUESTION
TO- PRESIDENT DOWNTURN. AGAIN
THE BRITS RELIABILITY IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WE DO
HAVE TO PREPARE FOR THESE
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO ME IS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO ELECTRIFY OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ON TOP OF
EVERYTHING ELSE. AND SO THE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY THAT'S GOING
TO BE NEEDED SPECIFICALLY AS WE
TRY TO MEET OUR TRANSPORTATION
GOALS. IT THIS IS ENORMOUS SO
THE QUESTION IS HOW IS THE
ELECTRIFICATION PROCESS BEING
CONSIDERED IN REGARDS TO THE-
OVERALL DEMAND. AND THE
RELIABILITY OF THE GRID AND
WHAT STEPS IS THE CPUC TAKING.
TO ADDRESS THIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION NEVER ON
THE ELECTRIFICATION OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- AS YOU SAY
AS YOU STATED WE ARE MEETING
OUR GHG GOALS- IN AND THE
ENERGY SIDE OF THE FENCE WE ARE
BEHIND- AND THEN IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE AS CHAIRMAN
HAWKSHAW SAID- SOME OF THE
THINGS THE GOVERNOR HAS DONE
NOT NOT ONLY IN THE MAY REVISED
EARLIER AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ARE
CRITICAL TO ADVANCING MORE LIKE
TO VACATION- OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION- SECTOR WHICH OF
COURSE IT REPRESENTS ABOUT
SIXTY PERCENT. OF OUR G. H. G.
SO. IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT- I
THINK I THINK CHAIR HAWK SHIELD
REALLY DESCRIBE VERY WELL THAT-
AS WE INCREASE OUR ELECTRIC.
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
AND THE WORLD FOR THAT MATTER.
THOSE ARE LITTLE POWER PLANTS
PLANTS IF YOU WILL THEY THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO STORE A GREAT
DEAL OF ENERGY AND THAT ENERGY
CONNECT BE EXPENDED- WHEN IT'S
MOST NEEDED. AT TIMES OF DAY
WHEN- SOLAR AND WIND ARE
ABATING- SO WE ARE WE HAVE
PASSED SEVERAL ON DECISIONS
THAT HAVE- FUNDED OR- ALLOWED
FOR PROCUREMENT OF NOT ONLY ON.
EXPANSION OF. CHARGING STATIONS
IN SAN DIEGO AND IN AND THE SAN
DIEGO SERVICE TERRITORY IN THE
EDISON TERRITORY PRIOR TO MY
COMING ON TO THE COMMISSION
THERE'VE BEEN OTHER. MAJOR
EXPANSIONS OF WHAT WE AS A
COMMISSION HAVE DONE IN TERMS
OF ELECTRIC- VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS IN PARTICULAR- I
REALLY THINK THAT SURE HOW
SHE'LL PROBABLY HAS A GREAT
DEAL TO STICK TO- SAY ABOUT THE
SUBJECT AS WELL IF I MAY TURN
TO HIM. TO ADD TO THAT THE
RESPONSE. THANK YOU
PRESIDENTIAL I WOULD JUST ADD
YOU KNOW IN THE MAY REVISED
BUDGET YOU KNOW THERE'S- A TWO
POINT ONE BILLION FOR THE
ENERGY COMMISSION HALF OF THAT
WE'RE PUTTING INTO
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
IN CONCERT WITH A MAJOR PUSH
FROM FROM THE PC- AND CARBS
WELL BECAUSE THE TOP PRIORITY
FOR US BUT IT IS ACTUALLY
MANAGEABLE- JUST FOR CONTEXT IT
OFF FIVE MILLION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA IS
EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT AN 8%
INCREASE IN OUR ELECTED DEMAND.
HOW WITH YOUR PERMISSION
ASSEMBLY WOMAN LIKE TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUE COMMISSIONER GOODELL
JUST TO SPEAK TO THIS. BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN DOING THE MODELING
FROM A- AS THOUSAND YEAR CAN UP
WITH ANSWER. WOULD TO REMIND
YOU I'M FROM EMINEM- SO I VERY
SPECIFICALLY INTERESTED ALSO IN
WHAT IS HAPPENING. IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND ALSO
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY- VEHICLES
AS OPPOSED TO JUST LIKE DUTY
YES LET ME LET ME SPEAK TO THAT
IF I COULD BRIEFLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE AUTOMOTIVE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR EVERY
SINGLE MAJOR. AUTOMOTIVE
MANUFACTURER IN THE WORLD IS
INTRODUCING AN INVESTING
HEAVILY NOW IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- THE FORD F. ONE FIFTY
WHICH PRESIDENT BIDEN- VISIT
THAT MANUFACTURING FACILITY
THAT IS GOING ELECTRIC. IN THE
SECOND QUARTER OF NEXT YEAR'S
CHEVY SILVERADO ALSO COMING OUT
WITH A FOUR HUNDRED MILE RANGE.
ELECTRIC VERSION AND YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE MUCH MUCH MORE
THAT INTO MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
AS WELL- OBVIOUSLY TEXAS MAKING
ELECTRIC SEMI THERE'S A THERE'S
A BUNCH OF ACTIVITY THERE- I
THINK WE'RE SEEING THE LIGHT
DUTY PASSENGER SECTOR START-
SORT OF THE PIONEER BUT THEN.
AS BATTERY COSTS COME DOWN
BASICALLY A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
KILOWATT HOURS WHEN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE BECOMES CHEAPER. THAN A
CONVENTIONAL VEHICLES WERE
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY NOW BUT
THERE'S A PATHWAY TO GET TO
EIGHTY- SO THIS IS WHY ALL THE
CAR COMPANIES ARE INVESTING.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THIS
MASSIVE SHIFT BY THE END OF
NEXT YEAR. THE NORTH AMERICAN
MARKET WILL HAVE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MODELS OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AVAILABLE FOR SALE SO.
A HUGE INCREASE OUR PREDICAMENT
YOU'RE GONNA. MAYBE YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
QUESTION. YEAH I'M THINKING. M.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. THE
QUESTION THEY'RE JUST HIGH
LEVEL I THINK I WANT TO COVER
TWO OR THREE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING DO. I TO HELP PREPARE
FOR THIS AND SINCE. SO WHAT I
THINK IS TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT ON WE AND WE ARE IN
TERMS OF. THE PEAK DEMAND
CONTRIBUTION AND THE ENERGY
CONTRIBUTION. FROM ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TODAY I WANT TO BE IN
ANTICIPATING IN TWENTY THIRTY
AND WORK WITH ANTICIPATING IN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND WHAT ARE
THE THINGS WE ARE TRYING TO DO
ON. ENSURING WE COULD USE SOME
OF THOSE AS STORAGE ON THE- OF
THE OTHER TECHNICAL SUPPORT
FROM A CHARGING PERSPECTIVE BUT
ALSO. CONVINCE THAT'S PERFECT.
SO TO BEGIN WITH TODAY THE
OTHER TWO VEHICLES CONTRIBUTE
AND REALLY NEGLIGIBLE OF BOOKS
pWELL AS- THE PEAK DEMAND
PERSPECTIVE. THAT LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT. OUR CURRENT MODELING I
SUGGEST THAT AT THE END OF
TECHNICALS WILL CONTRIBUTE. A
CLOSE TO A ONE POINT NINE ARE
CLOSE 22% AFTER THE PEAK DEMAND
IN TWENTY THIRTY. AND UPWARDS
OF 4% CLOSE 25% IN TWENTY.
THIRTY EST ANIMAL CONSUMPTION
GOALS. IN TWENTY FIFTY OR
TWENTY FORTY FIVE TIME FRAME
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT NUMBER
EXPANDING TO ALMOST 20% OF
ELECTRIC ENERGY USAGE IN THE
STATE. SO A FEW THINGS WERE
TRYING TO DO WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW THE OF CHARGE
TODAY AND GATHER INFORMATION
AND DOUBLE UP SCENARIOS ON HOW
THEY CAN OPTIMALLY CHARGING
DECLARED. A TIE SO AS A PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY I FOR. THE
QUESTION THAT THE LAND A FEW
SCENARIOS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
BEST TO CHARGE TO ENSURE
GREATER. WE MODEL SOME OF THOSE
AT THIS LAST YEAR AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MODEL THEM- TO
PROVIDE MORE SITUATIONAL
BUSINESS. ON THIS TOPIC YOU
ALSO RAISED A COUPLE OF OTHER
ISSUES SB SIX TO DEMAND
RESPONSE. AS WELL AS THE ARMY
SOURCES. SO WE ARE MODELING AS
A PART OF THE SP. ONE HUNDRED
AND NOW SAYS AS WELL AS THE ANY
THIRTY. HOW DO TO THINK ABOUT
AVAIL. AND DRD SOURCE ON THE-
AND YOU THINK TO WHAT THAT'S ME
FROM A BULK AT TO A
DISTRIBUTION. A GOOD PLANNING
AND IN CLOSE CO. WITH CPUS. AND
PROVIDING DOZEN. THE SO. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE A- AS QUESTIONS
IF YOU HAVE BUT THAT'S A HIGH
LEVEL CALL. OKAY AND YOUR
QUESTION. I COULD A GOOD TO
HAVE THE X. GIVING ANSWERS WE
JUST GET ASK ANSWER ASK THE
QUESTION. BUT I DID HAVE A
QUESTION FOR OWN. CHAIR CHILD.
AND WANT TO GO BACK TO THE IN
THE FINDINGS ON THE ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS. IT'S SUGGESTED AND
I'LL QUOTE THE ENERGY ENTITIES
SHOULD PRIORITIZE AND
ARTICULATE A CONTINGENCY PLAN.
IN THE EVENT FURTHER
ANTICIPATED EVENTS OCCUR SO
THAT THE EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES
THAT OCCURRED IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ARE READILY
MOBILIZED IF NEEDED. NOW IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SO YOU
SEE IS ACTUALLY WORKING ON THIS
CONTINGENCY PLAN THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE BEFORE SUMMER. I
ASKED MY STAFF WHEN THE SUMMER
BEGAN THEY SAID JUNE TWENTIETH
SO MY QUESTION IS WILL THE
CONTINGENCY PLAN BE READY
BEFORE JUNE TWENTIETH. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WERE ACTUALLY I
I'D LIKE TO ASK COMMISSION GOOD
TO SPEAK TO THAT IS DEVELOPING.
YEAH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST AT A HIGH LEVEL OF THE
CONTINGENCY PLANNING- WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF MEASURES THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I.
PROVIDE THE CONTEXT HERE OKAY
SO HAS TAKEN A NUMBER OF
ACTIONS TO TEST ESTABLISHED IN
MEANS THAT HAS MENTIONED. TO
REALLY THINK THROUGH SOME TABLE
TOP EXERCISES ON THE SOME OF
THE CONTINGENCIES. I JUST.
ANSWER THE QUESTION A TEN
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL AND WE CAN
GO INTO DETAIL IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONTINGENCIES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AND TALK THROUGH THE
PROCESS ON HOW BEST TO ENSURE
THAT THIS CONTINGENCIES ARE
AVAILABLE. ARE SOME OF THE
CONTINGENCIES INCLUDE OUR
DEPENDENCE ON THE NEIGHBORING
BALANCING AUTHORITIES- IN
COORDINATION WITH THAT CPAC HI
SO. WE DID A SUMMER AT IN THIS
WORKSHOP A WEEK AGO AFTER A
WEEK AGO AND THAT'S THAT'S YOU
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF OUR
PARTNERSHIPS. SO WE EXPECT A
LOT OF SUPPORT FROM OUR
BALANCING AND NEIGHBORING
BALANCING AUTHORITIES- WE DO
HAVE A VERY CLOSE COORDINATION
I HAVE A D. W. R. I. TO FIGURE
OUT HOW BEST THEY CAN SUPPORT
OF SOMEBODY AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO. SUPPORT SIGNIFICANTLY LAST
YEAR- BUT THAT DOESN'T. LOOK
LIKE A FEASIBLE AS WE MOVE IN
BECAUSE OF THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS BUT THEY WILL STILL
DO WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO. ON THE
TOP OF THAT AND INTERESTING
MEANS THERE AND- LISTENED AB
THAT'S IT HAS MENTIONED AT THE
EFFORTS ON AND SPECIFICALLY THE
FLEX ALERT THAT'S ANOTHER
CONTINGENCY. OVERALL BETWEEN
THE NUMEROUS AMOUNT OF
CONTINGENCIES THAT WE CURRENTLY
ARE TRACKING VERY CLOSELY. WE
WE BELIEVE CAUTIOUSLY THAT
THAT'S ENOUGH TO. SUPPORT AN
EXTREME SITUATION. IN IN
SPECIFICALLY ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION ON BAND THAT WOULD BE
PUBLIC- WE ARE HOPING TO MAKE.
KIND OF A WRITTEN DOCUMENT AT A
HIGH LEVEL PUBLIC FROM THE
THREE AGENCIES- IN A MONTH.
TIME FRAME THAT JUST PROVIDES
HIGH LEVEL COORDINATION ELEMENT
AND HIGH LEVEL MEASURES WHAT.
THANK YOU- I WILL BEFORE I TURN
TO KIRK WHO HAD A COURSE ASKING
WHY TO SCANNED THE ROOM. WAS
THE CUNNINGHAM WE HAVE- ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WITH TO ASK THE
SUMMIT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MY QUESTION IS FOR MR MAINS-
AND IT'S JUST A SIMPLE ONE BUT
I'M CURIOUS AS TO. HIS TAKE ON
IT- WHAT IS THE STATE'S SINGLE
GREATEST RISK FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THIS YEAR. WELL I THINK FOR
THEIR REMAINDER OF THIS YEAR.
YOU KNOW WORSE I THINK WE'RE
NOPE WE'RE SAT LARGELY SAID AT
THIS POINT WITH THE GENERATION
FLEET WE HAVE A WE'VE GOT OUR
OUR ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE I
THINK IT IS GOOD SHAPE WE
POSSIBLY CAN BE IN TERMS BOTH
THE GENERATION FLEET THE
TRANSMISSION LINES. I THINK THE
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION
PROTOCOLS HAVE BEEN VASTLY.
IMPROVED I THINK THERE WERE IS
THE OUR OF A EXTRA HOT WEST
WIDE HEATING ABOUT NO THAT'S
WHAT US LAST YEAR AND THAT'S
THE THIS THAT I THINK PLAN THE
GREATEST FOR- WE KNOW THIS YEAR
WERE ALL EX. A WARM CHAMP- THE
HYDRO CONDITIONS NOT JUST AS
THEY WILL BE LIKE TO BE
SIGNATURE BELOW AVERAGE THE
THIS MORNING TO GRAB WHAT THIRD
DRY WATER YEAR RECORD. IN SO
THE HIGH CONDITION OR STRESS.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING FIRES AND
SO YOU KNOW IF WE SEE THIS
PATTERN. OF EXTREME HEATING.
THAT CONTINGENCY PLAN. THAT
COMMISSIONER GOING TO JUST TO
GOING TO BE DEPLOYED- VERY VERY
ACTIVELY AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAVING TO MAXIMIZE
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION
AMONGST ALL THE UTILITIES. AND
WE WILL BE ASKING CONSUMERS TO
TAKE SPECIFIC STEPS SPOKE
BEFORE. OF THE HEATING VENTS
YOU KNOW THE MORNING THE
AFTERNOON PRE COOLING THEIR
HOMES. LOOKING FOR WAYS TO KEEP
THE- KEEP THE HOMES THIS
COUNTRY AS POSSIBLE EVEN PRE
PRE COOKING MEALS AND THEN WE
GET TO THE FOUR O'CLOCK TO NINE
PM OUR- WHEN THE GRID STARTS
EXPERIENCING THAT STRESSES THE
SUN STARTS SETTING IN ROAD
SPEAK UP- WILL BE ASKING FOLKS
TO. YOU KNOW REALLY REDUCE
THEIR USE OF MAJOR APPLIANCES.
HOW TO TURN OFF UNNECESSARY
LIGHTS. AND ALSO IF THERE
HEALTH SUPPORTS IT TO KEEP THAT
THERMOSTATIC ROUGHLY SEVENTY
EIGHT DEGREES AND COLLECTIVELY.
IF THEY LEAN IN WITH US. WE
CAN. HOPEFULLY MAKE IT THROUGH
WITHOUT ANY ROTATING OUTAGES
THE PRESENT EXTREME HEATING
SCENARIO. THAT IS THE ONE THAT
I THINK WE'RE MOST WORRIED
ABOUT. THANK YOU. OUR DOCTOR
GROUP YOU HAD A THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU CHAIR- WE'VE TALKED
QUITE A BIT OF THE- THE PANEL
HAS ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NET IMPORTERS. OUR WHICH I
SUSPECT. HAS A LONG HISTORY
PROBABLY FOR FINANCIAL REASONS
THAT IT'S PROBABLY CHEAPER TO
IMPORT THEM TO BUILD A PLANT
HERE OR YOU KNOW WHAT DOES
BECAUSE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
DOING SO MUCH MORE IMPORTING
AND EXPORTING. I CHANGE I CAN
SPEAK TO THAT- SURE PRESIDENT
DR WE CAN GET. YOU KNOW HOW
CALIFORNIA IN WHICH WE ARE WE
ARE IN MANY WAYS FORTUNATE AND
YOU KNOW WE SAW THIS PLAY OUT
EARLIER THIS YEAR. NO TEXAS
WOULD THAT THAT WE ARE PART OF
A VASTLY CONNECTED WESTERN
UTILITY GRANT. AND CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ACTUALLY AT THE NET
IMPORTER OF ELECTRICITY FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS AND
IT SPEND. SOMETHING IN MANY
WAYS IT'S BEEN MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL. FOR THE CHASE
REGION AYE AYE I SPENT THE LAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS WORKING ARE A
PART OF A PARENT MINISTRATION
WE ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THOSE IMPORTS WE ARE THE
EXPORTER TO CALIFORNIA DURING
THIS. LATE SPRING AND THE
SUMMER IS THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OUR OF OUR AVAILABLE HYDRO
AND THEN WHEN WE GET INTO THE
WINTER WHEN CALIFORNIA CHEST
STRAP LOWER LEVELS WE WOULD
IMPORT OUR- HOW TO CALIFORNIA
TO THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST FOR
WINTER PEAKING SYSTEM SO THE
EXCHANGE OF ENERGY CAPACITY
BETWEEN REGIONS IS VERY
VALUABLE AND WE HAVE AN
IMPORTER. THE PROBLEM AND THE
CHALLENGE NOW THAT WE HAVE TO
PAY MUCH MUCH MUCH GREATER
ATTENTION TO. IS JUST.
RECOGNIZING THAT AS WE CHANGE
OUR REESE MAY AND WE WERE TO
THE CAR VERSUS AND WE ARE SELF
NATURAL GAS- THE WHICH THE
NATURE F THE TYPE OF RESEARCH.
THAT WERE PUTTING ON THE GRID-
IN CONTINUE TO THAT CLASS.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCE
ACROSS THE WAY. THERE'S A LOT
OF TRANSMISSION IN. THE ACROSS
THE WEST WE CAN. TO TAKE A OF
THIS CAPABILITY BUT NOT BECOME
OVERLY RELIANT TOWARD AND
CERTAINLY HIGHLY CONSCIOUS THE
OF THE WHEN. OF THE BACK OF.
AND CONTINUE CAPE. IF WE GET
INTO THIS EXTREME HEAT. EVENTS
SO I CAN. HOW WERE. BONNEVILLE
POWER TO. YOU GOT MORE THAN YOU.
NOW AREA. BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'RE IMPORTING I BELIEVE FROM
ALL OVER THE WEST AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS. WHAT BECAUSE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE LESS GENERATION IN
THE STATE- SO THAT WERE NET
IMPORTERS. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE KNOWS THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION OTHER THAN ITS
ECONOMICS BUT- MAYBE THE CPUC
OR THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS AN
IDEA. WELL NUMBER I THINK YOU
NAILED THE- THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD IT'S IT IS IT DOES HAVE TO
DO WITH ECONOMICS AND IT ALSO
HAS TO DO WITH THAT. AS AS
PRESIDENT- AND CEO MEANS- IT IS
SAID IT ALSO HAS TO DO WITH
WHERE- WHERE THE ENERGY IS ONE
THERE'S NEATLY UP WE HAVE
STATES THAT- WE'RE NEIGHBORS
NEIGHBORS OF OURS THAT HAVE A
GREATER NEED IN THE WINTER THAN
WE DO AND WE HAVE A GREATER
NEED IN THE SUMMER THAN THEY DO.
SO IT'S SAY A FLOW AND THAT
LUCKILY WE'RE- VERY. CAPABLE OF
MANAGING AND- TAKING PART OF-
BUT I WOULD SAY IT'S BOTH THE
TYPE OF SEASONAL NEEDS WE HAVE
AND ECONOMICS. I WOULD JUST ADD
TO THAT ONE ONE POINT OF
SETTLEMENT KIRK WHICH IS I
THINK IT DOES A CREW TO OUR%
BENEFIT OVER TIME TO BE
CONNECTED TO THE REST OF THE
WEST AND IF YOU COMPARE HERE
WE'RE ALL HERE IN THIS HEARING
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE OF AN OUTAGE THAT
LASTED TWO HOURS ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH AND THEN OUR HALF ON
AUGUST FIFTEENTH AFFECTED ABOUT
HALF MILLION CUSTOMERS THE
OUTAGE THAT TEXAS HAD. FEBRUARY
WAS FIVE HUNDRED TIMES WORSE SO
pCONSERVE THEY HAD- EIGHT
HUNDRED WHAT ARE THE CONCERNS.
AND THEY ARE FUNCTIONALLY AN
ISLAND AND SO I THINK VERY MUCH
YOU KNOW. THEY WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE HAD- YOU KNOW ACCESS TO
SURROUNDING RESTORED MEAN JUST
GENERALLY. I DO THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE REST
WEST- HAS ITS BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIA. YEAH I TURN NINETY
THREE ON THAT. I'M CERTAINLY
SUPPORTER OF A WIDER BALANCING
AUTHORITY WITH THE I SO.
CALIFORNIA IS SO MERGING WITH
OTHERS BUT- WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
A- A NICE DREAM HOW NOT SURE
WE'LL EVER GET THERE BUT DIE I
APPRECIATE THAT- THERE'S-
BETTER COOPERATION BETWEEN THE
BALANCING AUTHORITIES AND MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT WILL HAVE TO DO IF
WE CAN'T. GET AROUND SOME OF
THESE POLITICAL PROBLEMS BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE IF I MAY I'D JUST
LIKE TO ADD ONE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU KNOW.
CALIFORNIA IS GOING THROUGH-
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE
ADEQUACY. CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW
IN AND REALLY WORKING ON THAT
ISSUE WITH A WITH ALL OF ITS
CAPABILITY BUT WE ARE NOT
UNIQUE IN THAT- THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS NOW. PLAYING
ACROSS THE WEST UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY ALL OF THE MAJOR
SUBREGIONS AND WESTERNIZED
STATES ARE DEPENDENT 21 DEGREES
ANOTHER ON IMPORTS. AND
ACTUALLY THE COMPETITION FOR
THOSE IMPORTS IS NOW BECOMING
INCREASINGLY. STRONG AND SO ONE
OF THE KEY THINGS ARE GIVEN
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO BUY
POWER FROM OTHER REGIONS IS
THAT TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH
WERE DEPENDENT. ON THOSE
IMPORTS FOR OUR PEAK NEEDS WE
NEED TO HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
DO FORWARD CONTRACTING IN LINE
AT THE SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT FORWARD BASIS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT ARE UTILITIES IN
THE STATE INCREASING ATTENTION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEDGING. THEIR EXPOSURE TO
BILLS PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL
RISKS IT'S A IT'S THAT FORWARD
CONTRACTING IN THOSE LONGER
TERM- BILATERAL RELATIONSHIPS.
INTO THE BROADER MARKET THAT
COULD SUPPORT THAT CAN HELP US.
MANAGE THAT INTERDEPENDENCY
WITHOUT IT. BECOMING TOO MUCH
OF A LIABILITY FOR US. YEAH MY
CONCERN THERE IS JUST THE WE
HAVE ALL THE C. C. MANY OF
WHICH ARE QUITE SMALL. AND
DINNER SO I WORRY ABOUT.
COORDINATION OF THE GOING TO BE
SUPPLYING. OF VERY LARGE
FRACTION OF THE STATE'S ENERGY
PROBABLY ALL OF IT IN SAN DIEGO
AND PATERNITY- AND- JUST THE
FACT THAT THERE. MANY OF THEM
ARE JUST VERY SMALL IT'S HARD
TO SEE HOW THAT- HOW WE
COORDINATE THAT. DR KIRK REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- THAT QUESTION
AND CERTAINLY ALL I CAN TELL
YOU IS KEEP THE FAITH- THERE
IS- OR THERE'S A WILL THERE'S A
WAY- IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS I HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ASK AND
THEN WE'LL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- AND AS DR COURT
MENTIONED A CALIFORNIA REMAINS
STRONGLY IMPORT DEPENDENT. HOW
MUCH CONFIDENCE DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER WESTERN WIDE HEATWAVE
OCCURS THAT OUR IMPORTS WILL
SHOW UP. AND WHAT ADDITIONAL
INSIGHTS OR TOOLS WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR OUR SYSTEM PLANNING
GIVEN THE REGIONAL NATURE OF
OUR ELECTRIC GRID AND RESOURCE
PORTFOLIO. WHAT DO YOU WANT TO.
EXPLAINING IT THAT FIRST YEAH
OKAY YOU KNOW YOU KNOW-
CHILDREN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR QUESTION AND JUST FOR FREE
SHAKE IT GENTLY YOUR ENGAGEMENT
UP ON THOSE TOPICS YOU KNOW
THE- THE ISSUE OF IMPORTS AND
THE CONSEQUENCES OF A
WIDESPREAD HEATING EVENTS- ARE
THE SINGLE PUBLIC BIGGEST RISK
VARIABLE- THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT OUR OUR SUMMER
ASSESSMENT THIS UC'S ANALYSIS
ARE ALL LOOKING AT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT AND SO ALL
OF OUR CONTINGENCY PLANNING.
ALL OF OUR RISK ASSESSMENTS ARE
REALLYBASED ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO RIDE TO THAT SCENARIO WITH
BETTER RESULTS THAN WE HAD LAST
YEAR AND I WOULD EMPHASIZE YOU
KNOW THE COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION AND THE
COLLABORATION WITH OUR ADJACENT
SYSTEM OPERATORS AND UTILITIES
IT'S JUST BECOMING A BIGGER AND
BIGGER PART OF OUR FUTURE
SUCCESS IN SERVE BETWEEN THE
BRIGHTNESS ROUND TABLES AND THE
TABLE TOP EXERCISES. AND OF
COURSE- TO CONTINUED
STRENGTHENING OF OUR ENERGY
IMBALANCE MARKET AND THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED WITH WITH UTILITIES
ACROSS THE WEST WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS A PATHWAY TO NOT ONLY
STRENGTHENING OUR ABILITY TO
WRITE THROUGH DISTURBANCES LIKE
WE SAW LAST SUMMER BUT JUST IN
GENERAL I TO CREATE MORE
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
VALUE FOR CALIFORNIANS AND INTO
CREASE THE EFFICIENCY AND THE
ABILITY AND THE RESILIENCE. OF
OUR SYSTEM SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE- OUR OUR EFFORTS TO
WORK AS COLLABORATIVELY WITH AS
POSSIBLE WE HAVE UTILITIES
ACROSS THE WEST REACHING OUT TO
CALIFORNIA. UNDERSTANDING OR
CODEPENDENCY IS A WARNING TO
CONTINUE TO CALL OF ALL BUT
THAT'S NOT I THINK IT'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO
DERIVE VALUE FOR ALL OF OUR
CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA IN
INDIA AND DRIVE PROGRESS ACROSS
THE WEST AS WELL. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE BOB WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WE'LL TURN TO ANYONE WHO'S IN
THE GALLERY FIRST IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE TWO SPEAKERS. ON PUBLIC
COMMENT WHO WERE IN THE GALLERY
OF- WILL TURN TO YOU KNOW WE
SENATORS. THANK YOU GOOD AFTER
MR CHIU MISTER BY CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TERRELL OF
LAJOS ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY WE DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES-
ATTENTION TO- RELIABILITY PG&E
IS COMMITTED TO SAFELY
DELIVERING RELIABLE AND CLEAN
ENERGY FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AND
WE'RE DOING OUR PART. IN MORE
TO HELP THE STATE ACHIEVE ITS
RELIABILITY OBJECTIVES EVEN
THOUGH P. GENIES ENERGY.
CREASED AS CUSTOMERS HAVE
MIGRATED TO OTHER LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES. WE HAVE NEVERTHELESS
BEEN ASKED TO STEP UP AND
SUPPORT STATEWIDE RELIABILITY
EFFORTS INCLUDING BY PROCURING
RESOURCES FOR NON PG&E
CUSTOMERS ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS
FOR THIS SUMMER. WE'RE DOING
MUCH OF THIS THROUGH THE CPC'S
ENERGY EMERGENCY RELIABILITY
PROCEEDING- WHICH EARLIER THIS
YEAR DIRECTED THE IOUS TO
PROCURE SUBSTANTIAL. DEMAND AND
SUPPLY SIDE RESOURCES FOR THIS
COMING SUMMER ON BEHALF OF
DOZENS OF LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
IN THE AYE SO FOOT PRINT.
DESPITE A TIGHT ENERGY SUPPLY
MARKET IN THE WESTERN U. S. AND
UNIQUELY TIGHT TIMELINES TO
PROCURE INCREMENTAL RESOURCES
FOR THE SUMMER PG&E IS LEAVING
NO STONE UNTURNED IN OUR
EFFORTS TO HELP THE STATE
PROCURE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
IN ADDITION TO THE EMERGENCY
PER CLIPS ARE SUPPLY
PROCUREMENT. WE ARE MAKING
OTHER EFFORTS SUCH AS SOFTWARE
UPGRADE CENTER GATEWAY AND
COLUSA GENERATING STATIONS TO
INCREASE THEIR OUTPUT WE CAN
DEPLOY A TEMP CHEN DESIGNED FOR
PS PS IF NEEDED- WE'VE ALSO
PROCURED HUNDREDS OF MEGAWATTS
OF BATTERY STORAGE- MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THAT WERE PART OF
PRIOR. CPUC ORDERS MUCH OF
WHICH HAVE. CONTRACTUAL ONLINE
DATES OF AUGUST FIRST. AS
PRESIDENT BADGER MENTIONED
THERE ARE MANY DEMAND RESPONSE
EFFORTS FOR THE MONTH OF AUGUST
AND SEPTEMBER P. GINNY IS
TARGETING TO PROVIDE FOUR
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS THROUGH OUR
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS AND OF
COURSE CUSTOMERS. HEAVY
OUTREACH- TO OUR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
TAKE ACTION TO HELP REDUCE
THEIR ENERGY DEMAND DURING HOT
SUMMER DAYS. AND FINALLY MISTER
CHAIR IN CONCLUSION. IF DESPITE
THESE BEST EFFORTS THE I SO
DETERMINES THERE IS A
RELIABILITY EMERGENCY AND
ORDERS ROTATING OUTAGES THIS
SUMMER. WE'RE PREPARED TO
IMPLEMENT THE ISO'S DECISION
THROUGH A NEW PROCESS OPERATED
REMOTELY BY SKATER. THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO EXEMPT THE CENTRAL
CUSTOMERS FROM ROTATING OUTAGES
IMPACT YOUR CUSTOMERS AND
RESTORE POWER MORE QUICKLY.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXT BAKER CHAIR HOLDEN
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON AND
MEMBERS I'M VERY MULLIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
LOCAL PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES THAT SERVE A QUARTER
OF THE STATE. RELIABILITY IS
PARAMOUNT AND CALIFORNIA'S PO
USE TAKE SERIOUSLY THEIR
OBLIGATION TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. MORE THAN
HALF OF THE STATE'S PO YOU'D
PROVIDE ELECTRIC SERVICE AND
COMMUNITY OWN BALANCING
AUTHORITIES WHICH MANAGE THE
FLOW OF ELECTRICITY. DURING THE
AUGUST THE WAY THESE COMMUNITY
ON AGENCIES HELP SUPPLY POWER
TO THE ISO GRID OR REDUCE THEIR
ISO IMPORTS. THE STATE'S OTHER
PO USE SERVE IN THE ISO
BALANCING AUTHORITY DURING THE
AUGUST THE WAY THESE PEOPLE
USING COURAGE CUSTOMERS TO
CONSERVE ENERGY. A RAMPED UP
THEIR OWN GENERATION OUTPUT TO
ASSIST THE GRID. ALL CALIFORNIA
PO USE HAVE BEEN WORKING SINCE
AUGUST TO FURTHER ENHANCE THEIR
SUMMER PREPAREDNESS INCLUDING
COORDINATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ISO. THE PEER USE
OUR PARTNERS IN ENSURING
RELIABILITY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DIALOGUE AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE CHI SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- THERE ARE ONLY
TWO THAT I UNDERSTOOD WE'RE IN
THE GALLERY THAT HAD COMMENTS
BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
pSUPPLY CHEERING COMMITTEE- MY
NAME SUNNY SUMMER I REPRESENT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY AND WORK CLOSELY WITH
ANOTHER NUMBER NUMBER OF MY PO
YOU PARTNERS- SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY. SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE READINESS AND RELIABILITY
IS A KEY AND HIGH PRIORITY FOR
NCPA. AND THE EVENTS OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND C. K. AND ARE. YOU
PARTNERS WORK TO SUPPORT RELY
BILLION SYSTEM BY INCREASING
GENERATION CAPACITY DURING HIGH
LOAD EVENTS AND DURING TIMES OF
NEED. WORK TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION PRODUCED IN OUR
COMMUNITIESTO SUPPORT
RELIABILITY. ALSO WORKED TO
CONSERVE. POWER AND WORK FOR
THE CUSTOMERS TO INSURE THAT WE
COULD HELP REDUCE STRESS FROM
THE GRID. BUT AS WE WILL AS WE
WORK TO LEARN FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THE INCIPIENT
APPEAR YOUR PARTNERS. ARE
SQUARELY FOCUSED ON ENSURING
THAT WE'RE WELL PREPARED AND
POSITIONED TO SUPPORT
RELIABILITY IN THE SYSTEM
LOOKING FORWARD. TO THE KEY
AREAS THAT WE'VE REALLY FOCUSED
ON THIS PART OF OUR
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES. IS
FOCUSED ON RESILIENCY TO ENSURE
THAT WERE PROPERLY MAINTAINING
OUR GENERATION FACILITIES SO
THAT. THEY'RE READY TO OPERATE
AT THE TIME OF NEED. FOCUSING
ON ENSURING THAT WE MAINTAIN. A
FUEL- DEPENDENT FIELD-
DURABILITY IN OUR SYSTEM
PARTICULAR WE OWN AND OPERATE A
NUMBER OF LARGE HYDROELECTRIC
FACILITIES. IN THE LIGHT OF THE
CURRENT DROUGHT CONDITIONS IN
THE SYSTEM SAY. WE'RE WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT WE MAINTAIN AS
MUCH DISCRETIONARY GENERATION
AS POSSIBLE SO WE CAN. SUPPORT
THE GRADE AT THE TIME OF NEED
ALSO WORKING TO MANAGE AND
HARDEN OUR SYSTEMS FOR WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS. IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT IN PAST EXPERIENCE AS
A RESULT OF CERTAIN WILDFIRE
CONDITIONS. SOME OF OUR
GENERATION FACILITIES ARE
UNABLE TO OPERATE DURING TIMES
OF NEED SO WE'RE ACTIVELY
WORKING TO. IMPLEMENT MEASURES
TO MITIGATE THAT RISK SO THAT
IN THE EVENT THAT WE
EXPERIENCED THIS TYPE OF
CONDITIONS. THE CHANCE OF A
GENERATION BEING AVAILABLE AS
HIGH I. AND EMPATHETIC SECONDLY
FOCUS ON HIGH LEVEL OF
COORDINATION EFFORT AS NOTED IN
THE DISCUSSION DURING THE PRIOR
PORTION OF THIS MEETING. WE
HAVE AND WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH OUR GREAT OPERATOR TO
ENSURE THAT WE TEST OUR LINES
OF COMMUNICATION. SO IN THE-
MOMENT OF NEED WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE CAN COORDINATE AS
CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE AND WE
SHOULD RESPOND IN A COORDINATED
WAY. WITH A GREAT OPERATOR AND
ALSO WORKING ACTIVELY WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS AND ENGAGE WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS TO INSURE THAT WE
DEVELOP. PROPER COMMUNICATION
TOOLS SO WHEN THE SYSTEM IS
UNDER STRESS CONDITION WE HAVE
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
COMMUNICATE THAT SITUATION
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS FOR
CUSTOMERS. TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
CONSERVATION AND IDENTIFY
GENERATION SUPPORT THROUGH. THE
USE OF DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
RESOURCES WE JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE THESE COMMENTS TODAY TO
ASSURE THE COMMITTEE THAT WE
ARE WORKING AT WORKING ACTIVELY
OUR PARTNERS TO ENSURE. WE'RE
PREPARED FOR THE SUMMER- IN
FRONT OF US. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS IS
THERE ANYONE. ELSE IN THE
GALLERY THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
MAKE A STATEMENT OR ASK A
QUESTION. SAN NINE WILL TURN TO
OF WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. CERVONE
MODERATOR CAN YOU CHECK THE
LINE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
ON. LINE TO MAKE A COMMENT OR
ASK A QUESTION. THANK YOU. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AGAIN AT THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
FIRST SIGN OF THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE TERM MEMBER
LEARNING MORE REPRESENTING SAID
MAC WHICH IS- THE ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS THE DEMAND
RESPONSE IN THE STREET.
SACRAMENTO BUT WE HEARD TODAY
DEMAND RESPONSE POLITICAL WON'T
STABILIZE IN THE GREAT LAST
AUGUST FADING AND TAKE A LOT OF
POWER EVEN THOUGH MARKET
CONDITIONS ARGUABLY ONE WERE
NOT IDEAL. TO SUPPORT THAT
CONTRIBUTION FOR EXAMPLE THE
RESOURCES HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD THAN OTHER RESOURCES.
IN ORDER TO BE RESOURCE
ADEQUATE YOU NEED. IN ORDER FOR
DEMAND AFTER THE DEMAND
RESPONSE WEEK RESOURCE TO BE
WELL. AND BE ABLE TO BE
UTILIZED IN THIS ENVIRONMENT IT
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE
OPENLY IN THE MARKETPLACE. WITH
FEWER CONSTRAINTS. INTO WAR FOR
QUESTION REMOVAL OF SOME OF THE
CURRENT IMPEDIMENTS THAT
EFFECTIVELY CONSTRAIN. THE
UTILIZATION OF THIS RESOURCE.
CLAIM IF ABOLITION OF A D. R.
REDUCE PARK. FOR THIS COMING
SUMMER. THE ELIMINATION OF
COULD PROCUREMENT. X. BUDGET
FOR THE DEMAND RESPONSE ACTION
MECHANISM GRAM. BUT I ATTENTION
THE RIVER. TO D. R. RESOURCE
METHOD THANKS SO MUCH FOR THANK
YOU. THANK NEXT TO GO TO LINE
OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TRIED LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A SON YOU. YOU
CAN HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK YOU HELLO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY- AND AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT MY NAME IS JULIA POSH
NICK AND I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION AMONG THE CPC CC
CAROUSEL AND THE HARD WORK TO
THE STAFF AND APPEARING FOR THE
SUMMER IN THE PROCUREMENT OF
SHORT TERM STORAGE. WE
ENCOURAGE THE AGENCY TO KEEP
THE MOMENTUM TO PLANNING FOR
CARE LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE THE UPCOMING- SUMMER
TEACHER. VERY A LOT OF GREAT.
MIGRATION ENERGY STARTED A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO ENSURING
CALIFORNIA CAN WHICH IS KIND OF
GO. AS OUTLINED IN AS HE
HUNDRED. AND WE HONOR CLIMB
EMERGENCY ARE BECAUSE NEARLY IN
THAT. THE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
FOR TWO. PERMITTING AND
BUILDING THAT AT THIS. AND CAN
MAKE. THE FACTORY CAN MOVE
TOWARDS OUR ENERGY GOALS.
COURSE BEGIN COUNCIL THAT ON
THE STATE. AND YOU CAN TO
APPROACH. OUR KIND OF DEADLINE
EIGHTY MUST FOCUS ON INCLUSIVE
ACCORDING PLANNING. FOR THEM
THE IN SECURING NEW CLEAN AND
RESEARCH. A CALIFORNIA AGENCY
WE CAN STEPPING TO MAKE HAPPEN
QUICKER WE ARE OF AN INCORRECT
PRESSURE THESE CLEAN ENERGY
EFFORTS. ALLEN IN THE FINAL
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS REPORT IN
THE LAST HONEST I CATCH THE
MORE ACTIONS THAT CAN BE
COMPLETED THIS SUMMER THE
BETTER OUR CHANCES IN THE
ARTICLES WILL BE. FOUNDATION
AND STORAGE. THE COURT THE
WEAPON AGENCIES AND AGREES TO
STAY IS INSTRUCTOR POSITION
GOING INTO SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE LAST SUMMER CAROUSEL'S
GPT HAS UNDERTAKEN A NUMBER OF
OPERATIONAL REVENUE OUT OF THE
ATTENTION NOTHING LIKE JEFFREY
WILL BE AVAILABLE THIS SUMMER
BUT WE CAN'T STOP THERE AND
MUST CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK AND
INSURANCE I'M SURE WE ARE
PLANNING A PROCURING FOR THE
NEXT YEAR AND NEXT. POSTED BY
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE CHALLENGES
OF MAINTAINING AVAILABLE GRAD
ACCIDENT EXPECTED TO GROW IN
THE COMING DECADES AGO MARGARET
NOBLE COME ONLINE MY BASIC
RESOURCES ARE TAKEN OFFLINE I
LIKE TO SEE DEMAND GROWS FROM
ELECTRIFY. THE TRANSPORTATION
AND BUILDING SECTORS. ON SHARED
USED. ON SOCIAL TO. PROVIDING
THE GRADE WITH AN SERVICES
FLEXIBLE. I'M LIABLE TO FROM
THE COST. FOR THE WORKING THE
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES. TO ENSURE
WE ARE READY FOR THE NEXT
COMPLEMENT THE- THANK YOU CAN
THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE.
REMOVING A COLON UNDER WE CAN
BE YOUR WORK. AND DEDICATION TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU NEXT
A LITTLE ONE OF TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR NUMBER-
THAT YOU'RE HOLDEN BY SURE
PATTERSON BURKE AT THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT BACK AND WE ON
BEHALF OF DIRECT ENERGY AND IS
CURRENT COMPANY AND R. G. THANK
YOU TODAY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING AT AGE DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDER IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO MEET THE COST
ANALYSIS. RECOGNIZING THAT NOT
ONLY THEIR ACTED PROVIDERS HAD
MET OUR RESOURCE ADEQUACY
OBLIGATION BUT ALSO HAD THE
MOST ACCURATE DATA HAS MOBILE
CAPS WHICH MINIMIZE THE BURDEN
ON THE CALIFORNIA I. S. O. TO
MAKE A BILL CURRENT ADJUSTMENT
LAST AUGUST. CURRENTLY DIRECT
ENERGY IS EXCEEDING OUR BY OUR
KEY RESORT ADEQUATELY
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS BY 40%
WENT LONG TURN SOLAR AND ENERGY
STORAGE CONTRACT. MEDIA REPORTS
SAID ALONG WITH THE DIVERSE BIO
ENERGY AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES
IN OUR PORTFOLIO GOLD POSITION
I BELIEVE COMPLY WITH OUR RPI
IN A ONE HUNDRED OBLIGATION. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WITH
YOU HOW WE CAN HELP COMPETITION
WITH WITH- CCESS MODEL HELP
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
RELIABILITY CLEAN ENERGY AND.
AFFORDABILITY COOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
ABOUT LINE OF THE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ADAM
GAME. AND I'M THE WESTERN EDGE
OF ADDRESS BECAUSE OF CONCERNS.
I'M KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN TO
CLIMATE CHANGE DRIVING THE
INCREASE IN EXTREME THAT WERE
HE AND GET THREE THIRTY SHOWN.
THAT WITHOUT ACTION TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS BY MID CENTURY
PERCENT OF THE SUBSTATION IN
THE FAMILY VALUE WILL EXPAND
THIRTY OR MORE DAYS PER YEAR OF
EXTREME TEMPERATURES THAT COULD
LEAD. TO QUITE A DETERIORATION
AND FAILURE AND WE'VE OFFICE
ENOUGH INFORMATION LINE FROM
CONVOCATION UNDER EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS. SO WE SEE A
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE FOCUSED
ON RELIABILITY SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE I'M A CONCLUDE NON WIRE
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS THE MAN
RESPONDED ENERGY STORAGE. AND
MAYBE NOT CONTINUE. TO MOVE
AWAY FROM RELYING ON NATURAL
GAS POWER. IN ADDITION THE END
ELECTION WEATHER ON ENERGY.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
IN AND- COMMUNITIES- HIGHER
BILL THAT IN THE RATE- ON
FIFTEEN. I'VE LOGGED ARE THE ON
HEALTH AND PASS BECAUSE WITH
PARA. THE COURT AS A POLLUTION
IS BACKED BY OUR THE- WELL
INCOME AND- COMMUNITIES. I WANT
PROPOSAL THAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE SEE A- THE
SWINGLE. IS THAT COME
CALIFORNIA BAR NOT A LINE. THAT
WOULD COMPENSATE LOW INCOME HOW.
FORTY ENERGY USE DURING. DURING
SEVENTY PERIODS. SO HOPING THAT
THE AND CONTAINED TOOK SCHOOL
DEMAND ACCOMPLISH LIKE THAT ONE
OUT OF THE- I'M TRYING TO
INCREASE LIABILITY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT CAN YOU
COMMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND MY TO ONE AND THEN ZERO ANY
COM. MISTER WE HAVE NO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT Q. THANK YOU-
NOT A MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND I DO APPRECIATE ALL OF
THOSE WHO- DECIDED TO BE A PARTOF THIS HEARING TODAY AND TO
FIND OUT THE KIND OF WORK THAT
OUR- ENERGY ENTITIES HAVE BEEN.
ARE DILIGENTLY WORKING ON AND
THEN ALSO TO SHARE YOUR
COMMENTS WITH THE COMMITTEE IS
VERY HELPFUL TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS PROCESS-
I'D LIKE TO TURN TO OUR
MOISTURE- PATTERSON HE HAS SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS AND THEN IF
THERE ARE ANY. THOUGHTS THAT
ANY OF OUR PANELISTS MIGHT HAVE
THAT THEY LIKE TO TAKE. A
MINUTE AND MAKE- WE CERTAINLY
WILL- ALLOW THAT AND THEN WE
WILL CLOSE OUT THIS HEARING.
THRESHER THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
UP EIGHT YEARS- I HAVE SERVED
AS THE VICE CHAIR. OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE SAME.
DIFFICULTIES WE ARE FACING
TODAY ARE THOSE THAT WE HAVE
FACED IN RECENT YEARS. OUR
RELIABILITY IS DECREASING WELL
OUR COSTS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
TO RATE PAYERS. AND HERE WE ARE
TODAY GOING OVER THE SAME OLD
GROUND. RELIABILITY KEEPS OUR.
ELECTRICITY PROVIDERS- AWAKE AT
NIGHT. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PUT ENOUGH ELECTRICITY ON
THE GRID FOR THE DEMAND. AND AT
THE SAME TIME WE'RE SEEING
COSTS GOING UP. TO RATE PAYERS
AND WHAT OUR SOLUTIONS- SAYING
TO CALIFORNIANS WHEN YOU COME
HOME ON A HOT DAY STOP USING
YOUR AIR CONDITIONING BETWEEN
FOUR AND NINE O'CLOCK OR WASH
YOUR CLOTHES IN A MUCH MORE
INCONVENIENT TIME FOR COOK YOUR
DINNER DO OTHER CHORES THAT
REQUIRE ELECTRICITY AFTER NINE.
PM THIS IS NOT A REAL REALITY-
THAT MOST CALIFORNIANS CAN LIVE
WITH. ON TOP OF THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING TIME OF USE RATES.
PRICING AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY
IN THE AFTERNOON AND EVENING
OUT OF THE REACH OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WE ARE CREATING
WHAT AMOUNTS TO RATE INDUCED
SCARCITY. AND UNDER THE PHRASE
AND WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THAT TODAY AT DEMAND RESPONSE.
WE ARE LITERALLY POWERING DOWN
PORTIONS OF OUR ECONOMY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPLY.
THIS IS THE GRID THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED. IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY ON THE PLANET. HIGH
COST QUESTIONABLE RELIABILITY
PRICE INDUCED SCARCITY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE'RE FORCING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
MAKE THE EXCRUCIATING CHOICE.
YOU EITHER PAY RENT BUY
GROCERIES OR PAY THE
ELECTRICITY BILL. WE HEARD
TODAY FROM MANY OF THOSE WHO
HAD THE BUREAUCRACIES TO
OPERATE THIS GREAT. I AM MAKING
A PLEA FOR THE VOICES OF THOSE
WHO HAVE TO USE THIS
ELECTRICITY AND PAY FOR IT.
UNRELIABILITY GOES DOWN AND
COSTS GO UP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE FORCED AWAY
FROM AN ELECTRICITY GRID THAT
IS RELIABLE THAT THEY CAN GO TO
THE WALL TURN IT ON. CAN AFFORD
TO USE IT. WE CONTINUE TO SEE.
THIS DIFFICULT DICHOTOMY
RELIABILITY ON THE DECLINE.
COST ON THE INCREASE
ESSENTIALLY. TELLING PEOPLE TO
USE THEIR ELECTRICITY AT
INCONVENIENT TIMES. EMPOWERING
DOWN A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
OUR ECONOMY. I DON'T THINK THIS
IS AN ACCEPTABLE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND UNFORTUNATELY
IN EIGHT YEARS OF THE VICE
CHAIRMANSHIP HERE I HAVE SEEN
NOTHING- THAT WOULD SATISFY MY
CONCERN. THAT WE ARE CREATING
AN ADEQUATE GRID FOR THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE PLANET.
WE- THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE TO
THOUGH THAT WE'RE IN A
TRANSITION PERIOD. WHICH BEGAN
BEYOND THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE
MENTIONED ON YOUR SERVICE.
VALUABLE SERVICE TO THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT THE TRANSITION
IS MOVING US FROM FOSSIL FUELS
TO RENEWABLE FORM OF ENERGY
THAT CAN POWER GRID RECOGNIZING
THE IMPACTS OF A DROUGHT THAT
HAS A SUSTAINABLE DROUGHT. THE
RECOGNIZING THAT THE CLIMATE IS
CHANGING AND IMPACTING ON OUR
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO DO
THINGS AS USUAL THEY GOT US
INTO THIS MESS- WE ARE. WORKING
HARD AS YOU KNOW AND- AND OUR
ABILITY TO TRANSITION TO SMART
TECHNOLOGY. STORAGE AND OTHER
FORMS WE HAVE RESOURCES THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO EXPLORE.
CONSULTANCY AREA LITHIUM
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
US TO HAVE GREATER TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCES AROUND BATTERY
STORAGE. WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
TRANSITION. AND I BELIEVE AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS TRANSITION WE
HAVE BEEN VERY DILIGENT TO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE TAKING
THE APPROPRIATE STEPS TO
PROTECT THE RATE PAYERS. AS YOU
AND I HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO COLLABORATE ON. THE
DISCUSSION THAT LED TO A
QUESTION HERE TODAY. IN TERMS
OF WHAT DOES EXPANDING. OUR
IMPACT OF OUR GRID. AND
COLLABORATING WITH OTHER STATES
MEAN IN TERMS OF DRIVING COSTS
DOWN. AND WE HAVE SHOWN THAT IT
IS GOING TO BE VERY VALUABLE TO
THAT END. EVEN IN THE-
EXPLORATION OF THE ENERGY
IMBALANCE MARKET IS LEADING US
IN THE PAST THAT UNDERSTANDS
THAT THIS IS GOING TO GET US IN
A MUCH BETTER PLACE. SURE WE
ARE ABLE TO EXPAND ON THAT BUT
EVEN IF WE JUST ARE AT THE
PLACE OF UTILIZING THE YEAH I
AM IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. ECONOMIC BENEFITS. THE
SERVICE IS NOT EASY- THIS IS
VERY DIFFICULT AND WE'RE ALL
STRUGGLING. AS WE GO THROUGH.
YEARS OF MASSIVE WILDFIRES. NOW
HEAT WAVES THAT ARE IMPACTING
ON THE STABILITY OF THE GRID
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. MAKING
TRANSITION TO ADDRESS. THE NEED
TO TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUEL.
TO RENEWABLE ENERGY SO I THINK
THAT- IT'S NOT EASY BUT GREAT
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN EASILY-
REQUIRES COMMITMENT IT REQUIRES
DEDICATION IT REQUIRES.
PERSEVERANCE AND WE HAVE TO DO
THIS COLLABORATIVELY AS AN
ENTIRE STATE AS INDUSTRY AS
REGULATORY AS GOVERNMENT AS
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE STATE
EVERYONE DOING THEIR PART.
WE'RE IN UNCHARTED WATERS IN
MANY WAYS BECAUSE- WHEN LAST
SUMMER WE SAW A HUNDRED AND
22 DEGREES TEMPERATURE HEAT IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THOSE
ARE SET AS DEATH VALLEY.
TEMPERATURES SO THIS IS EVEN
OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS- THE
CLIMATE IS NOT HAPPY AND WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE THE BEST MOST
RESPONSIBLE TRANSITION AS WE
CAN SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE IT-
AND ALSO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
IS. RIGHTEOUS TO THE TO ALL
RATEPAYERS ALSO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER AND
TRY TO CONTINUE TO FIND THOSE
IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS TO THIS
PERPLEXING AND VEXING PROBLEM
I'LL TURN TO- OUR PANELISTS
AGAIN I'M- COURTESY IF YOU
HAVE- THIRTY SECONDS A CLOSING
COMMENT YOU DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE
ME UP ON THAT BUT I CERTAINLY.
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVING HEARD PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOU HAVE ANY. IN
PASSAGE YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH US. MISTER CHAIRMAN- THIS
IS MIRABEL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND MR VICE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR STATING THAT THIS
ISN'T EASY AND IT ISN'T. BUT
YOU HAVE OUR PLEDGE AT THE C.
P. U. C. I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM I. SO ALLIES SO AND FROM
THE CDC WOULD AGREE THAT. WE- I
THINK THAT CHAIR HOCHSCHULE
SAID THAT IS ONE TWO AND THREE
IN TERMS OF RELIABILITY AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS IN ALL OF OUR-
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF WORKEVERY
DAY HOW- HOW ABSOLUTELY
CONCENTRATED WE ARE AND DEVOTED
WE ARE. TO MAKING SURE THAT- WE
DO MEET THE RELIABILITY NEEDS
OF THE STATE BUT WE DO IT IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY. THAT IT
DOESN'T BREAK THE BACKS OF THE
RATE PAYERS IT'S SOMETHING WE
ALL ARE CONCERNED ABOUT AT ALL
TIMES. SO YOU YOU REALLY CAN'T
DO ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER YOU
MUST SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
PRIVILEGE TO. BE A PART OF THIS
HEARING TODAY AND ON BEHALF OF
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE C. P. U.
C. I. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HOLDEN AND- MEMBERS- I WOULD
JUST WHAT YOU HAD TO WHAT-
PRESENT THAT YOU JUST SAID
THERE AND MY ONLY POINT WOULD
BE. THAT THE MOMENT WE'RE IN
REALLY REQUIRES US TO DO. TWO
THINGS WE HAVE TO RESPOND TO
THE CRISIS THAT WERE INTO
WHETHER THEY WERE FACING- AND
THEN FOCUS ON ON THE RESILIENCE
OF TRYING TO BUILD BUT ALSO TO
THE UNDERLYING ISSUE WHICH IS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE CAN'T
LOSE SIGHT OF THAT EITHER
BECAUSE AS BAD AS THIS IS IT
COULD GET A LOT WORSE. IF WE
DON'T GET A HANDLE ON
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP. ON
BUILDING A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
MATTERS MORE THAN EVER ANDI
WOULD JUST- REMINDED WHEN YOU
KNOW THE SOLUTIONS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. SOLAR WINDS
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BATTERY
STORAGE THESE ARE INDUSTRIES
THAT WERE BORN IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE SCALING AROUND THE
COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD
BECAUSE- OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES
AND- THIS GOVERNOR PREVIOUS
GOVERNORS AND WE HAVE TO KEEP
KEEP GOING. TO PERFORM THE
CHILDREN GET TO SCALE- SO THAT
WE CAN BETTER PROTECT OUR STATE.
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. MANSER
YOU'RE YOU'RE ON MUTE. CHARLES
AN INVESTOR PATTERSON MEMBERS
NOT MUCH MORE TO BE SET UP AND
VOTE FOR PRESIDENT PATRICK
CHAIR WHO SHELLED. OF THE
PREGNANT VERY WELL I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT I THINK THE PRINCIPLES
THAT WE JUST GOT DISCUSS TODAY.
AROUND COMMITMENT AND FOCUS AND
PARTNERSHIP AND COLLABORATION
AND COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION THAT IF WE
PRACTICE THOSE. ON A REGULAR
BASIS KEEP OUR EYE ON THE BALL
MAINTAIN OUR FOCUS- THAT I
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY
PROMISING FUTURE ON THIS PATH
TO DECARBONISATION FROM ALL OF
US AT THE AYE SO WE REALLY
VALUE PARTNERSHIPS.
COLLABORATION AND THANK YOU
CHARLTON AS WELL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND KEEP MYSELF
FOCUSED IT'S GREATLY
APPRECIATED SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY FOR
TODAY. AND THAT CONCLUDES THIS
HEARING.